I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello, everybody.
我是珍娜·菲舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这部终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。大家好。
Hi. We are very excited about today's... episode. So we have arrived in our rewatch to threat level midnight. But we are not breaking that down this week. No. We're actually going to be breaking that down next week with writer BJ Novak. Yes. So if you do not already subscribe to Office Ladies, you might want to hit that subscribe button so you don't miss that one. Yes. And go over to Office Ladies on Instagram because we're going to be posting lots of photos and behind the scenes stuff. But I think we need to talk about what's about to happen today. This week, we thought we might reach out to someone
嗨。我们对今天的……这一集非常兴奋。在重温的进度中，我们终于来到了“午夜威胁级别”。但我们这周不打算剖析那一集。没错。我们实际上打算在下周与编剧BJ·诺瓦克一起剖析那一集。是的。所以如果你还没订阅《办公室辣妈》，你可能想点击那个订阅按钮，这样就不会错过那一集了。是的。去Instagram关注Office Ladies，因为我们会发布很多照片和幕后花絮。但我觉得我们需要谈谈今天即将发生的事情。这周，我们想联系一个人，
who loved this episode of The Office and is a huge office fan, so much so she even sampled the episode in one of her songs. Let's hear it. No, Billy, I haven't done that dance since my wife died. There's a whole crowd of people out there who need to learn how to do the scorn. Don't ask questions. You don't want to know. That's right. To be talking to you, Belatona. Should I take in a break, not an oxford come.
她超爱《办公室》这一集，也是这部剧的超级粉丝，甚至在她的其中一首歌里采样了这一集。我们来听听。不，比利，自从我妻子去世后，我就没跳过那种舞了。外面有一大群人需要学习怎么跳“蔑视舞”。别问问题。你不想知道的。没错。在跟你说话，贝拉托娜。我该不该休息一下，不是牛津大衣。
Take what I want when I want. And I want you. That's right. Billy Eilish is in the studio today to have a conversation with us about her love of the office. Oh my gosh. I know. I can't believe it. You guys obviously know Billy Eilish from her amazing music career at just 20 years old.
想要什么就拿什么。而我想要你。没错。比利·埃利什今天来到录音室，跟我们聊聊她对《办公室》的喜爱。哦，天哪。我知道。我简直不敢相信。你们当然知道比利·埃利什，她年仅20岁就拥有了惊人的音乐生涯。
She has won multiple Grammys. She's won an Academy Award. I mean, people's Choice Awards, Kids Choice Awards, Billboard Music Awards, I Heart Music Awards. Name an award, and she has probably won it. She also is a director. She directs her music videos. She has a book. She has a fragrance.
她获得过多次格莱美奖。她赢得过奥斯卡奖。我是说，人民选择奖、儿童选择奖、公告牌音乐奖、iHeart电台音乐奖。说出一个奖项，她大概都拿过。她还是一位导演。她自己导演音乐录影带。她有一本书。她有一款香水。
Her new album is called Happier Than Ever. It is out now. You can find out about all this stuff on her website. Billy Eilish.com, including her tour dates. And she's a super fan of the office. Like super fan. Super, super, super fan. And we are super fans of hers. So much so that we brought our kids in today. Yes. And here they are. They're in the studio. You guys want to say hi? Hi. Hi. Hi. Hello. Hi. Oh, those are our kidos. Yay. Are you guys excited to meet Billy? Yes. We are too. Yeah, for about a year now, Harper, you've been asking me what?
她的新专辑叫作《比以往更快乐》。现已发行。你可以在她的网站Billy Eilish.com上了解所有这些内容，包括她的巡演日期。她是《办公室》的超级粉丝。就像超级粉丝。超级、超级、超级粉丝。而我们是她的超级粉丝。所以我们今天把孩子们带来了。是的。他们就在这儿。他们在录音室里。你们想打个招呼吗？嗨。嗨。嗨。哈喽。嗨。哦，那是我们的宝贝。耶。你们很兴奋能见到比利吗？是的。我们也是。耶，大约一年来，哈珀，你一直在问我什么？
Hi. When can we meet Billy? Yeah. Yeah, you said if Billy ever comes on the podcast, can I please come meet her? Well, we should probably scooge on out of here because we just got a text that she's moments away. Okay, let's take a break. And when we come back, Billy Elish is going to be here. Woo! Yay!
嗨。我们什么时候能见比利？对呀。对呀，你说过如果比利上播客，我能去见她吗？好吧，我们大概应该溜出去了，因为我们刚刚收到一条短信，说她马上就到了。好吧，我们休息一下。等我们回来，比利·埃利什就会在这里。哇！耶！
Yeah! This is an ad by BetterHelp. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal? Do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? What helps you get through stressful moments? Mm-hmm. For me, it's talking it out.
耶！这是BetterHelp的广告。你知道，现在感觉好像对所有事情都有建议。就像，你写日记吗？你做过什么排毒、冷水浴，还是说，你知道是什么帮你度过每一天？是什么帮你度过压力时刻？嗯嗯。对我来说，就是把事情说出来。
Mm-hmm. Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true. and what actions to take these days. So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through BetterHelp. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on over 1.7 million client reviews.
嗯嗯，关于心理健康和健康的信息可能会严重过载，如今要想知道什么是真的以及该采取什么行动可能会是一场挣扎。所以你可以考虑使用一个值得信赖的资源，通过BetterHelp与真人治疗师交谈。根据170多万客户的评价，它在应用商店的评分是4.9分（满分5分）。
As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month, at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelphelp.com slash office ladies. Hello, it's Lena Dunham.
作为全球最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以为你提供各种不同专业领域的心理健康专业人士。通过BetterHelp倾诉。我们的听众在BetterHelp.com斜杠office ladies首次订阅可享9折优惠。网址是BetterHelphelp.com斜杠office ladies。你好，我是莉娜·邓纳姆。
I host a podcast called The Sea Word with my dearest friend and historian of bad behavior, Alyssa Bennett. What is up? It's a chat show about women whose society is called Crazy. We're going to be rediscovering the stories of women's society dismissed
我主持一个名为《The Sea Word》的播客，搭档是我最亲密的朋友兼不良行为史学家艾丽莎·班尼特。怎么回事？这是一个关于那些被社会称为疯狂的女性的聊天秀。我们将重新发掘那些被社会解雇的女性的故事，
by calling them mad, sad, or just plain bad. Listen to and follow the C-word with Lena Dunham and Alyssa Bennett, available now wherever you get your podcasts. Philly Isish is here today on Office Lady. Philly Isish is here. I'm here. Hi, guys. Thank you for coming. Thank you for having me.
称她们为疯狂、悲伤或纯粹的坏。收听并关注莉娜·邓纳姆和艾丽莎·班尼特主持的《The Sea Word》，各大播客平台现已上线。菲莉·伊什今天来到了Office Lady。菲莉·伊什来了。我来了。嗨，大家好。谢谢你们的到来。谢谢邀请我。
In studio, right here right now. We're really excited to talk all things office with you. Oh, me too. Where should we start? Oh, my gosh. wherever you would like. Okay, I'm going to kick us off. How did you discover the office?
在录音室里，就在此时此地。我们非常高兴能跟你聊聊《办公室》的一切。哦，我也是。我们该从哪里开始？哦，天哪。你想从哪里开始都行。好吧，我来开个头。你是怎么发现《办公室》的？
Was it with your family? Did you watch it with your folks? Well, okay, so as a little kid when this was all starting, I didn't watch it as a kid, because it's not a kid show. It's not super appropriate. No, it's not.
是通过你的家人吗？你和你的长辈一起看的吗？好吧，所以当这档节目刚开始时我还很小，我不是作为一个小孩子看的，因为它不是儿童节目。它不是很适合儿童。不，确实不是。
But I would hear it all the time and I would hear people talk about it and that's what she said was constantly being said, and I remember it was a really big part of my childhood was not understanding what that's what she said meant. Oh, no. And I would, I'd get very, very frustrated.
但我经常听到别人谈论它，而且“她刚才就是这么说的”这句话经常被挂在嘴边，我记得我童年的一大块记忆就是听不懂“她刚才就是这么说的”是什么意思。哦，不。而且我会，我会感到非常非常沮丧。
And I would ask people, what does that mean? You know what you would explain it to me. I don't ever remember hearing the first time about the office. Like it was just, I just knew about it forever. It was like the beginning. Yeah, I don't remember. I don't remember finding it. I don't remember hearing about it.
我会问别人，那是什么意思？你知道你会向我解释的。我不记得第一次听说《办公室》是什么时候了。就好像，我一直都知道它。就像是生命的起点。是的，我不记得了。我不记得我是怎么找到它的。我不记得我是怎么听说它的。
I just, it was just part of life. It was like, you learn to speak and you don't, there's not like a day that you learn to speak. You're just speaking. Yeah. And so that was kind of with the office. And then I just didn't understand that's what she said. And I remember there was a specific moment. I must have been nine years old.
它就只是生活的一部分。就像，你学会了说话，你不会，并没有哪一天是你专门用来学说话的。你自然而然就会说话了。是的。所以《办公室》差不多就是这样。然后我就是听不懂“她刚才就是这么说的”。我记得有一个特定的时刻。我当时一定只有九岁。
And I was sitting in my kitchen. And my mom had a bunch of people over that I didn't really know. And somebody said something and somebody said that's what she said. And everybody laughed. And I remember understanding it for the first time. And being like, let's fucking go. And then that was like, I was like, okay, got it. And then you're like, TWSS.
我正坐在厨房里。我妈妈家里来了一群我不太认识的人。然后有人说了句话，另一个人就接了句“她刚才就是这么说的”。所有人都笑了。我记得我第一次真正理解了那个梗。当时心想，太特么绝了。然后我就觉得，好吧，懂了。然后你就会说，TWSS。
Got it. Yes. And then I got like into that. And then I must have started watching it when I was probably 11. Do you remember the first episode you saw? I think I started it from the beginning. Really? I've seen it now.
懂了。是的。然后我就开始迷上这个了。接着我大概在11岁左右开始看这部剧。你还记得你看到的第一集是什么吗？我想我是从第一季第一集开始看的。真的吗？我现在已经看过了。
I believe it's about 30 times. 30 times? All the way through. You're a purist. Yeah. Do you only watch it in order? Do you skip around? Sometimes I skip specific episodes.
我坚信大约看了30遍。30遍？从头到尾完整的30遍。你是个纯粹主义者。对。你只按顺序看吗？还是会跳着看？有时候我会跳过特定的剧集。
Oh. I can't wait to hear that. It's honestly, like, Scott's Tots, I can't handle it. Oh. Is that the cringiest for you? Can't do it. It's so cringe. secondhand embarrassment, I just can't handle it. When we've been doing our rewatch, the one that
哦。我迫不及待想听听了。说实话，比如《斯科特的 tots》，我真的吃不消。哦。那是你觉得最尴尬的一集吗？看不了。太尴尬了。那种代入式的尴尬，我实在受不了。当我们重温这部剧时，有一集让我
hit me hard was Prince Family Paper. Yeah, that broke my heart. When they take down that sweet family paper company and how bad he feels about it, it's hard breaking. I don't think I could watch that one again. I think I'd have to skip it. That was hard for me. Well, so for you guys, have you guys watched it all the way through fully or no? Okay, this might break your spirit. No, no, it's Okay, I get it. Okay. We are rewatching it for the first time all the way through together. I mean, we'll catch an episode here or there like on a plane or maybe it will come up on Comedy Central or you know what I mean over the years. But this is the first time I have sat down and done a full rewatch.
感触很深，那就是《普林斯家族纸业》。对，那一集让我心碎。当他们搞垮那家温馨的家族纸业公司时，以及他对此感到多么内疚，这太让人心碎了。我想我无法再看那一集了。我想我不得不跳过它。那一对我来说太难了。那么对你们来说，你们是从头到尾完整地看过了，还是没有？好吧，这可能会打破你们的幻想。不，不，没关系，我懂。好吧。这是我们第一次一起从头到尾完整地重温这部剧。我的意思是，我们会在飞机上偶尔看上一集，或者在喜剧中心频道（Comedy Central）偶然看到，你知道我的意思，这些年偶尔会看。但这是我第一次坐下来完整地重温。
Yeah, watched it in order from beginning to end. Yeah. When it originally aired, we would get together as a cast and we would have cast screenings on Thursday nights and watch it in each other's living rooms. And so I saw most of the episodes then. but I didn't watch every single episode. And so there's going to be a few that I haven't seen before. I'll be seeing them for the first time, which is crazy. It is crazy.
对，从头到尾按顺序看。是的。在它最初播出的时候，我们会作为演员聚在一起，在周四晚上举行演员观影会，在彼此的客厅里看剧。所以那时候我看过大部分剧集。但我并没有看每一集。所以会有几集是我以前没看过的。我将是第一次看到它们，这太疯狂了。这真的很疯狂。
Oh, my God, you haven't seen all of them? Not all of them. I would say 98%. Yeah. We tried to watch everyone when they aired. But it is very surreal because you're watching a version of you from, my God, what is it, 15 years ago? Yes, yeah. You know?
哦，天哪，你没有看过所有的剧集吗？不是全部。我会说看过98%吧。是的。我们尽量在每集播出时都看。但这种感觉真的很超现实，因为你在看一个从，天哪，大概15年前的你自己？是的，没错。你知道吗？
I mean, who was the kid that came? up to you and was like, you look like an older version of Pam. And you were like, I am an older version of Pam. Yeah. Oh, no. He said, when was that? I was in a Target and he was like, I'm sorry. Has anyone ever told you, you look like an older version of the person who played Pam on the office? And I said, I am an older version of the person who played Pam on the office. Oh, my God. And he kind of didn't believe me. He wasn't sure. No, they don't. But that happens. I mean, a lot of people discover the show. through streaming and don't really have a concept of like how old it is, how far it goes back.
我是说，那个走过来对你说“你看起来像是年长版的帕姆”的小孩是谁？而你说“我就是年长版的帕姆”。是的。哦，不。他说，那是什么时候？我在塔吉特（Target）超市，他对我说：“不好意思，有没有人说过，你长得像在《办公室》里扮演帕姆的那个演员的年长版？”我说：“我就是那个在《办公室》里扮演帕姆的演员的年长版。”哦，天哪。他当时有点不相信我。他不太确定。不，他们不会相信。但这种事确实会发生。我的意思是，很多人都是通过流媒体发现这部剧的，对它有多久的历史、能追溯到多久以前并没有什么概念。
I know, because it hasn't really aged. I don't feel like it's aged much. It feels, it doesn't feel like an old show to me. There's some shows you watch and it's like, this feels old. I mean, maybe like people, because of the way the world is, it's aged in terms of humor. We say entertainment was a timestamp of when it was made. Yeah. That's all I think it would be, but it hasn't aged. It's aged very well, in my opinion. Yeah, it holds up. It does. It cracks me up. Billy, I have a question. This is from my daughter Harper.
我知道，因为它真的没有显老。我觉得它没怎么变老。它给人的感觉，对我来说它不像一部老剧。有些剧你看的时候会觉得，这感觉好老旧。我是说，也许人们会觉得，因为世界在变，它的幽默感带有时代的痕迹。我们说过娱乐作品是一个时代的产物。是的。我想大概也只有这点不同，但它并没有变老。在我看来，它经久不衰。是的，它经得起时间的考验。确实如此。它让我捧腹大笑。比利，我有个问题。这是我女儿哈珀问的。
She would like to know if you could only watch one episode of the office for the rest of your life, which one would it be? Oh, my God. I wouldn't want to watch just one for the rest of my life. I've thought about this a lot, though. Honestly, rewatching it, I just, I fall in love with different parts of it and different episodes every time. But my favorite kind of, one of my favorites was my favorite for a long time was beach games. That one really gets me. Yeah, it just gets me.
她想知道，如果你余生只能看《办公室》的一集，你会选哪一集？哦，天哪。我可不想余生只看一集。不过我经常思考这个问题。说实话，在重温的过程中，我每次都会爱上它不同的部分和不同的剧集。但我最喜欢的一种，我曾经很长一段时间最喜欢的一集是《海滩游戏》。那一集真的打动了我。是的，它深深触动了我。
The scene where... Actually, the scene where Andy is in the sumo suit, and then he's, like, so sad, and it's this really heart. He's, like, slow, like, he's like, oh, it, like, hurts my stomach. Like, the way he's looking at the water, and he slowly just wants to touch the water, and then he falls in, and then you're there, you're like, I can't hear you, what? He's like, get help. Poor Ed Helms.
安迪穿着相扑服的那个场景……实际上，安迪穿着相扑服，然后他显得，那么伤心，这是一个非常走心的。他慢吞吞的，就像，噢，它，就像，我的胃好痛。他看着水面的眼神，然后他慢慢地只想碰一下水，接着他就掉进去了，然后你在那儿，你会说，我听不清你在说什么，什么？他说，快来救命。可怜的埃德·海尔姆斯。
You know that's really Ed. Even when he's floating far away, it was not a double. We just floated Ed out in that river. There was a man in a little, like, rowboat thing with a rope tied to Ed, and he would, like, pull him out. Oh, my God. I know. I loved that. I got to walk across the hot coals.
你知道那真的是埃德本人。甚至当他漂得很远的时候，那也不是替身。我们只是把埃德漂在那个河里。有一个人坐在一个小小的类似划艇的东西上，有一根绳子系在埃德身上，他会把他拉出来。哦，天哪。我知道。我太喜欢那个了。我得走过滚烫的碳火。
Uh-huh. Was it actually hot coals? No. Did I make you believe it was? Yeah, you did. Tell me what it was, because I think it's just as painful. It was. So it was like real lava rocks over. They dug a ditch in the ground, and then they kind of filled it with some lights, with gels to give it that glow. And then on top of that, they put like real lava rocks. And then along the side were real flames. So. Oh, so it was still really warm. It was sort of warm. Like, they were very specific. Do not get near the edges of this firewalk thing, this coal walk.
嗯哼。那真的是烫的炭火吗？不是。是我让你相信它是真的吗？对，你确实做到了。告诉我那到底是什么，因为我觉得它同样痛苦。确实是。所以那其实是铺在上面的真正的火山岩。他们在地上挖了一条沟，然后用一些带滤光的灯填满它，营造出那种发光的效果。然后在那上面，他们放了真正的火山岩。接着在旁边是真正的火焰。所以。哦，所以它其实还是挺暖和的。有点温热。就像，他们的要求非常具体。千万不要靠近这个火行区、这个炭火行走区的边缘。
You saw your bare feet on a little sharp little... Thank you. I say it was like running over a bunch of Lego. Yeah. Eek. How that feels. So it was painful, but not because it was hot, just because it was like digging into my feet. Yeah. And how many times did you do it?
你赤脚踩在一点点尖锐的小……谢谢。我说它就像踩着一堆乐高积木跑过去一样。是的。呃。那种感觉。所以确实很痛，但不是因为烫，只是因为它们像在扎我的脚。是的。那你走了多少次？
I think we did about three takes. Okay. Yeah. So not too bad. Pretty good. Yeah. And it was cold. It was so cold.
我想我们大概拍了三个镜头。好吧。所以还算不错。挺好的。是的。而且当时很冷。天气太冷了。
What was your guys is, like, what was your favorite episode to shoot? Oh. I love this question because it's not what our favorite episode is. Because filming it. That's what I mean, right? That's what I mean. Yeah. Because that's another question of like, what is your favorite episode?
你们俩觉得，拍摄时最喜欢的一集是哪一集？哦。我喜欢这个问题，因为这和我们最喜欢的剧集不一样。因为这是关于拍摄过程的。我是这个意思，对吧？我就是这个意思。是的。因为那是另一个问题，比如你最喜欢哪一集？
What's your favorite episode that you shot? You've got a lot of big questions. I think I can actually sum it up into one answer. Okay. I'm going to say Dundies because we were out of the office kind of for the first time. And we were on a location and it had a slumber party feel to it. Because we didn't really have trailers or anywhere to go. And we were just hanging in that fake chili.
你最喜欢拍摄哪一集？你的问题可真不少。我想我其实可以把它们总结为一个答案。好吧。我选《办公室颁奖典礼》，因为那是我们第一次离开办公室。我们在外景地拍摄，有一种睡衣派对的感觉。因为我们真的没有化妆车或任何可以去的地方。我们只是待在那个假的辣椒酱里。
And for like, you know, 12 hours, we're just in that one room. Yeah. And it was just fun and funny and nonstop. And I got to be drunk. Yeah. Or pretend to be. Steve kept improvising with Rain on that keyboard, you know. Yeah.
而且你知道，我们要在那一个房间里待上12个小时。是的。而且很有趣，很搞笑，一刻不停。我还可以演醉酒。是的。或者假装喝醉。史蒂夫一直在用雷恩的那个键盘进行即兴表演，你知道的。是的。
Dwight would do different things and we kept cracking up. Well, don't give Rain Wilson a keyboard that makes sound. No. Unless. Or a burp noise. Yeah. No. That was a lot.
德怀特会做各种不同的动作，我们一直在狂笑。好吧，可别给雷恩·威尔逊一个能发出声音的键盘。没错。除非。或者打嗝的声音。是的。不。那可真够呛。
He was just going crazy with it. To the point. where I think they were like, hey, Rain, can you let Steve get through one without the sound of no, I totally remember because Steve, like, as Steve as Michael was making a speech, and Rain kept hitting the, oh yeah. Exactly. They were like, okay, you have to stop. Yeah. So that's your favorite to film and maybe one of your favorite episodes? Yeah, and here's the crazy thing because, you know, there was a big debate on that episode because we thought it might be the last episode of the office that ever aired. because, yeah, for that season, we only got picked up for six episodes.
他当时简直玩疯了。以至于我想他们当时在说，嘿，雷恩，你能让史蒂夫在没有声音的情况下顺利演完一次吗？不，我完全记得，因为史蒂夫，当时作为迈克尔的史蒂夫正在发表演讲，而雷恩一直按那个，哦，对。没错。他们说，好吧，你得停下来。是的。所以那是你拍起来最喜欢的，也许也是你最喜欢的剧集之一？是的，最疯狂的是，你知道的，那一集当时有很大的争议，因为我们以为那可能是《办公室》播出的最后一集。因为，是的，那一季我们只续签了六集。
Yeah. And it wasn't looking great. And so we had this big debate. Can you believe that when you think about it now? It's weird now, but that was our life for the first two seasons. At the end of the six episodes, they had our names, you know, on paper that they had laminated and velcrowed to our trailer doors. And I went and I un-veldcrowed my paper laminated name.
而且情况看起来不太妙。所以我们进行了激烈的讨论。现在想想，你敢相信吗？现在觉得很奇怪，但那确实是我们前两季的生活。在那六集结束时，他们把我们的名字，你知道的，打印在纸上，塑封好，然后用魔术贴粘在我们的化妆车门上。我走过去，把贴着我名字的塑封纸撕了下来。
I was like, well, that was fun. I'm going to take this on. Yeah. After the six episodes? Yeah. This was after, yeah, this was our season two pickup. Yeah. And we thought maybe Dundies would be our farewell.
我当时想，好吧，这挺有趣的。我要把它带走。是的。在那六集之后？是的。这是在，是的，这是我们第二季续订之后。是的。我们当时以为《办公室颁奖典礼》可能是我们的告别之作。
And I remember standing in the parking lot with Greg Daniels and saying, do we think Jim and Pam should kiss outside of the Dundies just in case there's no more episodes of the office? Ever? Like should we have it as an alt? Yeah, yeah. And then if they cancel the show, you can put that scene in. And if they don't cancel the show, we'll save it. And Greg said, no, we're not going to give them the option. If they want to see you two kiss, they're going to have to pick up the show.
我记得当时和格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）站在停车场说，我们觉得吉姆和帕姆应该在《办公室颁奖典礼》外面接吻吗，以防《办公室》以后再也没有新剧集了？永远没有了？我们是不是应该把它当成一个备用镜头？对，对。然后如果他们砍掉了这部剧，你就可以把那个场景剪进去。如果他们没有砍掉这部剧，我们就把它留着。格雷格说，不，我们不会给他们这个选项。如果他们想看你们两个接吻，他们就必须续订这部剧。
We're not going to give them the footage. That's right. But hold up. Pam does kiss. She does kiss Jim. Okay. I think they don't kiss till casino night. Are you crazy?
我们不会把这段素材给他们的。没错。但等等。帕姆确实亲了。她确实亲了吉姆。好吧，我觉得他们直到赌场之夜才接吻。你疯了吗？
She kisses them on the roof. I know, but it was like a sloppy fall into you kiss. It wasn't like kiss. Okay. I say, I know, I know. John and I argued about this too. You say Jim and Pam's first kiss is Casino Night? Yes.
她在屋顶上亲了他。我知道，但那是一个踉跄着扑到你身上的吻。那可不像是正式的接吻。好吧，我说，我知道，我知道。约翰和我为这事也争论过。你说吉姆和帕姆的初吻是赌场之夜？是的。
Well, that's their first, like, intentional... Smoo-y-Smooch. Together, you know, consensual kiss. Yeah. Yeah. Or their first, like, passionate, really, whatever. And, yeah, I guess in Dundies, it's more... You're drunk and you love him and he's your friend and you hug him.
好吧，那是他们第一次，带有主观意愿的……亲亲我我。在一起的，你知道的，你情我愿的吻。是的。是的。或者他们第一次，那种充满激情、货真价实的吻。而且，我想在《办公室颁奖典礼》里，那更像是……你喝醉了，你爱他，他是你的朋友，你拥抱了他。
My mouth is falling onto his mouth. Okay, well, you know what I mean? Like, that's like... I don't know about this far. The argument is getting weaker for me. No. No, but, you know, when we talk to John about it, John was like, from Jim's perspective,
我的嘴倒在了他的嘴上。好吧，你知道我的意思！就像，那是……我不知道是不是这样。这个论点对我来说越来越站不住脚了。不。不，但是，你知道的，当我们和约翰谈起这件事时，约翰说，从吉姆的角度来看，
they kissed. He got a kiss from this girl that he's liked forever. Yeah. Well, wouldn't you? Yeah, I would agree with Jim's perspective. Yeah. I get it, though. I hear it all.
他们接吻了。他得到了这个他喜欢了很久的女孩的一个吻。是的。难道你不会这么觉得吗？是的，我同意吉姆的看法。是的，我懂。我都听明白了。
What about you, and what's your favorite episode to shoot and or to? Oh, man, this is so hard. I loved filming the Christmas episodes. They were so huge. My character always lost her mind. You know what I mean? Just screaming and throwing ornaments and stomping. And I loved all of that.
那你呢，你最喜欢拍摄哪一集，或者最喜欢哪一集？哦，天哪，这太难了。我喜欢拍圣诞特辑。场面太宏大了。我的角色总是情绪崩溃。你知道我的意思吗？就是尖叫、扔装饰品、跺脚。我喜欢所有这些。
So filming Christmas was really fun. I loved the scene in Yankee Swap when we all sat in a circle and traded gifts. And I got that jazz poster, babies playing jazz instruments. Some people like these. Such a good line. And it hung by my desk for like years. I have one at home. I do.
所以拍圣诞特辑真的很有趣。我很喜欢“洋基交换”里的那个场景，当时我们围坐成一圈交换礼物。我拿到了那个爵士海报，上面是婴儿在演奏爵士乐。有些人就喜欢这个。这台词太棒了。它在我的办公桌旁挂了好多年。我家里有一个。我真的有。
But I feel weird putting it up because it is babies like with the playing instruments. Okay, but what my favorite episode is is changing all the time now that we're watching it. I feel the same. And I rewatched, oh God, it was so funny with my daughter, I rewatch the deposition. My character is barely in it. Like, really, I don't think I have a single line in it. Jan in that deposition. And then when they get Michael's journal and his journal is so dorky, but it's like I'm dorky.
但我觉得把它挂起来有点怪，因为它上面是婴儿在演奏乐器。好吧，但现在随着我们重温这部剧，我最喜欢的剧集一直在变。我有同感。我重温了，天哪，和我女儿一起看太搞笑了，我重温了听证会那一集。我的角色几乎没怎么出场。真的，我觉得我在里面连一句台词都没有。简在听证会上。然后当他们拿到迈克尔的日记时，他的日记太书呆子气了，但这就好像，我写日记时也很书呆子气。
when I journal. Oh, we know, Ange. Oh, it's really important. Do you journal? I love to journal. Okay, listen. You do? I do. Oh, okay. You've made Angela so happy. I journal, too, but she is such a dorky journaler. Well, we brought in one of my journals that I wrote in my 20s, and I was interning on Conan. I was living in New York. And I literally wrote something like, you'll never believe what happened today, but I got to run. Stay tuned. I'll fill you in later. XOXO, X-XO, Angela. Right? But that's like, who am I writing to? I'm such a dork. You're writing to yourself.
哦，我们知道，安吉拉。哦，这真的很重要。你写日记吗？我喜欢写日记。好吧，听着。你写？我写。哦，好吧。你让安吉拉太开心了。我也写日记，但她写日记的方式太书呆子气了。好吧，我们带来了我在20多岁时写的一本日记。当时我在柯南秀实习。我住在纽约。我 literalmente 写下了这样的话：“你永远不会相信今天发生了什么，但我得走了。敬请期待。我稍后再告诉你详情。亲亲抱抱，安吉拉。”对吧？但这就好像，我是在写给谁看啊？我真是个书呆子。你是在写给自己。
I know. Your future self. Oh, it's a big deal. It's cute. Do you journal, like, what do you journal? Is it just like free association? I journal, I journal on my phone because it's easier for me. Oh, yeah.
我知道。写给未来的自己。哦，这可是件大事。挺可爱的。你写日记吗，比如，你都写些什么？就只是随性联想吗？我写日记，我在手机上写日记，因为对我来说这样更方便。哦，是的。
I'm not a fast writer. And I just journal anything that I think because I noticed, I've noticed in my life that, you know, you get excited and you tend to lie to yourself about your life and your situation and, like, how you feel about stuff because you really want to feel something. Yeah. And then you think, well, if I just say that's how I feel, then that's how I feel. I've been journaling for a while, but this year I was specifically like, you know what? I feel like I've done a lot of lying to myself about how I'm really feeling.
我写东西不快。我只是把心里的任何想法都写在日记里，因为我发现，我生活中注意到，你知道，人一兴奋，往往会对自己的生活、处境以及对某些事情的感受自我欺骗，因为你太渴望某种感觉了。对吧。然后你会想，好吧，如果我说这就是我的感受，那这就是我的感受。我写日记有一段时间了，但今年我特别觉得，你知道吗？我觉得自己对真实的感受做了很多自我欺骗。
So I'm just going to, because I'm worried people are going to find it or post it or like tell somebody because that's a big fear of having this kind of life. Yeah. And so I just made a decision to just write down every thought like with, with the comfort that no one's going to read it, no one's ever going to know. Right. I'm not going to have to worry about it. It's just for me.
所以我打算，因为我担心别人会发现、把它发到网上或者告诉别人，这是过这种生活的一大恐惧。对吧。所以我就决定把每一个想法都写下来，带着“没有人会读、永远没有人会知道”的安慰。对吧。我不用担心这回事。这只是给我自己的。
Right. So I just write freely anything that I think, which is dangerous for sure. But it feels really good. It feels a lot better. It makes me feel good. Yeah. I have those journals. I have those journals from my 20s especially where I lay it all out.
对吧。所以我只是自由地写下我脑子里的任何想法，这当然很危险。但感觉真的很棒。感觉好多了。这让我感觉很好。对吧。我有那些日记。我特别留着20多岁时的日记，我在里面把一切都剖析得清清楚楚。
And I do have a slight fear that, like, I'm going to pass away and, like, my kids are going to find And these are not all the things that my kids need to know about me. So I have an agreement with Angela. They're in a special cabinet and I show Angela where they were. Okay. And so if anything happens to me, it is Angela's job to go in and burn the journals. And destroy them. Because they destroy them.
我确实有点担心，比如，万一我过世了，我的孩子们会发现……这些并不是我孩子们需要知道的关于我的全部事情。所以我跟安吉拉（Angela）有个协议。它们在一个特殊的柜子里，我把它们放在哪里告诉了安吉拉。好吧。所以如果我发生什么意外，安吉拉的任务就是进去把日记烧掉。把它们销毁。因为要把它们销毁。
They're for me. That's what she said. Oh, my God, dude. But this is your legacy, though. Like, you're you. I know. People want your words after you pass on, dude. Do I want people to have me?
这些是留给我自己的。她是这么说的。我的天哪，老兄。但这可是你的传奇啊，你知道的。你就是你。我知道。大家在你过世后还想看到你的文字呢，老兄。我希望别人拥有真正的我吗？
me. I don't know. It's mostly like, that's for me. And I like to go back and reflect. Like, I like to go back and be like, what was my mind at 27? Where was I? What did I care about? What was I interested in? What was I worried about? You know, and you see patterns over time when you review your journals. I see habits, habits of thinking, habits of behavior. It's really fascinating, you know? But it's so personal. I don't, I'm not sure. Like, in order to give me the freedom to really write it down, I need to know that Angela's going to burn them if anything happens to me. And I told her I will torch them. It's a best friend agreement.
我。我不知道。这主要是为了我自己。我喜欢回头去反思。比如，我喜欢回顾过去，想想：我27岁时在想什么？我当时在哪里？我关心什么？我对什么感兴趣？我担心什么？你知道的，当你回顾日记时，你会发现时间的规律。我看到了习惯，思考的习惯，行为的习惯。这真的很迷人，你知道吗？但这太私密了。我不知道，我不确定。为了让我有真正写下来的自由，我需要知道如果我发生什么事，安吉拉会把它们烧掉。我告诉她我会把它们烧成灰烬。这是闺蜜间的约定。
I mean, that's really sweet. So I'm glad you guys have that. You need a BFF who can torch. I know the problem is mine are all digital. So that's an issue. Well, I exist forever. It does. And I've started a few years ago.
我的意思是，这真的很贴心。所以我很高兴你们有这样的约定。你需要一个能帮你毁尸灭迹的闺蜜。我知道，问题是我的日记全都是电子版的。所以这是个问题。好吧。我会永远存在下去。确实如此。而且我几年前就开始了。
I know I'm like a dinosaur, but that notes app on my phone. Mm-hmm. So I love to write comedy. I love to, like, study people. So I have a whole notes on my phone. Jenna, I don't even know if I've ever shared this with you of just observations of people, situations, things that I might find funny. I have a handwritten notebook of that. You do? Yeah, I wrote one down the other day. I said, in case I ever need to play characters, I can look at all these notes. Woman who reapplies her lipstick immediately after finishing a meal. That's a person. That's a thing. That's a thing. That's a full character. I have a question for both of you. Because I know what some of this stuff is like.
我知道我像个老古董，但手机里的那个备忘录App。嗯——哼。我喜欢写喜剧。我喜欢研究人。所以我手机里有一整篇备忘录。珍娜（Jenna），我甚至不知道我有没有跟你分享过这个，里面全是对人、情境、我觉得好笑的事情的观察。我有一个手写的笔记本记录这些。你真有？对，我前几天还写下一条。我说，万一我以后需要演什么角色，我可以看看这些笔记。那种吃完饭立刻补口红的女人。这也是个人物。这是个梗。这绝对是个梗。这是一个完整的人物设定。我有一个问题想问你们两个。因为我知道其中一些事情是什么样的。
What did you hate doing or, like, the process of making? By the end of the run, it was less fun to sit in the background of all the scenes. I think about that a lot when I'm watching, because you guys really be doing that. Like, you guys are in the back of a lot of shots. Everybody. Like, all of the one-offs, like the talking heads. And you don't even think, when you're, watching you. Honestly, I don't even think about it unless, like, I religiously watch like
你们讨厌做什么？或者说，讨厌哪部分的制作过程？到拍摄后期，坐在所有场景的背景里已经没那么好玩了。当我看着回放时我经常这么想，因为你们真的在那么做。比如，你们在很多镜头的背景里。每个人。比如，所有的龙套角色，就像面对镜头说话的访谈。当你看着的时候，你甚至不会去想。老天，我甚至不会去想这事，除非我像个信徒一样狂看
the bloopers of all the stuff. And I, and that's when I notice, I'm like, oh, my God. Leslie David Baker and Creed are in the back. Yeah. In the back of every single one. Yeah. I know. For nine years. For nine years. I sometimes lucked out because I was behind a partition. And so I could be like, come on, guys. You can't see Angela ride in here. Come on. You can barely see me when I stand up. I know for me, the thing. that really got old was the fake pregnant belly because you had a body suit with the belly and it was itchy and heavy. And Jenna had it first and she was really griping about it. And I was like, okay, all right, it can't be that bad. And then I had it. And I was like, are you kidding me with
所有幕后花絮之类的东西。然后，我就会注意到，我心想：天哪。莱斯利·大卫·贝克（Leslie David Baker）和克里德（Creed）居然在背景里。对。在每一个镜头的背景里。对。我知道。长达九年。长达九年。我有时候挺走运的，因为我后面有个隔断。所以我就可以说，拜托，伙计们。你们不能看到安吉拉骑车到这里来。拜托。当我站起来时，你们勉强能看到我。我知道对我来说，那件
this thing? Like to go pee? Forget it. You're my... It was 20 minutes to get out of it. Under this pillow thing. Wow. So it's not just a belly. It's like a full piece. It's like a... It's like a wet suit. But then a little pocket that a belly goes down. So your legs and your arms are in that thing. Yeah. You step into it, right? And
真正让人厌烦的东西是那个假孕肚，因为你得穿一件带肚子的连体衣，又痒又沉。珍娜先穿的，她当时抱怨得厉害。我当时就想，好吧，好吧，不可能有那么糟糕吧。然后轮到我穿了。我当时就想：你们在跟我开玩笑吧，
how about this? We haven't gotten there yet. But when Robert California has this big party, we all go in the swimming pool and they had me swim with that fake belly. Guess what? It absorbs water. I was like, oh, bloat. I was like, oh my God. I thought you didn't sink to the bottom
这东西？去嘘嘘？想都别想。你得……花20分钟才能脱下来。在这个垫子底下。哇。所以它不只是个肚子。它就像是一整件衣服。它就像是一套……像一套潜水服。然后中间有一个放肚子的兜。所以你的腿和胳膊都套在那个东西里面。对，你得踩进去，对吧？还有
with your tiny self. I know. I got to a good core workout. Do you have a favorite season of the office? I do. You do. What is it? Okay. Three, four, and also five, but three and four are like unbelievable. Five is also incredible. Yeah. Incredible. But three and four, like, it's just like Jim and Pam get together around there. Things are good. We're like, Michael's not leaving yet. We're in a good zone, man. There's not conflict as much yet. There's not, like, the senator yet. There's not Robert California yet. There's not Joe.
这个呢？我们还没聊到那集。但是当罗伯特·加利福尼亚（Robert California）办那个盛大的派对时，我们全都跳进了游泳池，他们竟然让我挺着那个假肚子游泳。你猜怎么着？它会吸水。我当时就想：哦，膨胀了。我当时想：天哪。我还以为你不会沉到池底呢
There's not Gabe yet. And it still, it stays really good. But those just couple seasons are just like, yeah, happiness. Can I bring you into a controversy? Yeah, please. Do you think that it was okay that Jim bought his parents' house in Framed Toby without telling Pam first? Where do you stand? Romantic or controlling?
凭你这小身板。我知道。我练到了很好的核心肌肉群。你们有最喜欢的《办公室》某一季吗？我有。你真的有。是哪一季？好吧。第三季、第四季，还有第五季，但第三季和第四季简直好得难以置信。第五季也很棒。对。棒极了。但第三季和第四季，就好像是吉姆（Jim）和帕姆（Pam）差不多在那时候在一起了。一切都很好。我们当时觉得，迈克尔（Michael）还没走呢。我们在一个很好的状态，伙计。冲突还没那么多。还没出现……比如还没 senator（参议员）。还没罗伯特·加利福尼亚。还没乔（Jo）。
I don't love it. But also, people in their relationships, have their own what's okay and what's not. That's a great answer. Even though these are not real characters, they are in the show, and it's not, it's up to Pam whether it was okay or not,
还没盖布（Gabe）。而且它依然，真的保持着极高的水准。但那几季简直就是……充满幸福。我能把你们拉进一个争议话题吗？可以，请说。你们觉得吉姆在没有事先跟帕姆商量的情况下，就买下他父母在弗雷姆（Framed）的房子并把托比（Toby）气走，这样做对吗？你们站在哪一边？浪漫还是控制欲？
not me. Exactly, and I think it made Pam's like life. She felt so taking care of. And also what I liked was that at first, you're like, you thought this without telling me and like look at all these weird things going on. And you have this whole concern,
我其实不太喜欢。不过话说回来，人们在恋爱关系中，都有各自觉得什么可以、什么不行的标准。这是个极好的回答。尽管这些不是真实的角色，但他们在剧里就是这样，而且到底行不行，这得由帕姆来决定，
and everyone that's watching is like, yeah, what the hell is going on? Yeah. And then it's this very sweet, touching moment of you being like, I love it. Like, look at this. Like, I don't even care about any of the anything, but you bought me this, you know? You bought me a house. It's amazing. So it's like, I think you can see it from both sides. Like, I wouldn't want someone to do that in my life. But also it's like, it depends on the situation and the person and your life and the thing, you know. And I think also what came before it was Roy, who was so noncommittal. They were engaged for so. long. And then you meet us. And then you meet Jim who's like all in. Yeah. And how good that must have felt. Yeah. It's true, actually. And someone who didn't do anything for Pam ever. And then it's like, yeah, maybe it's so far the other direction that it could be too far. But it's so nothing like she's ever experienced that it's like really touching to do that, you know, which is sweet.
而不是我。没错，而且我觉得这几乎成就了帕姆的生活。她觉得自己被照顾得无微不至。而且我喜欢的一点是，一开始，你会想：你竟然不告诉我擅自作决定，你看这周围发生了这么多奇怪的事。你心里会有全方位的担忧，
It's interesting because when that episode came up, I said, and we've had these conversations, before, what do you do when something has been written for your character? Yeah, that you don't agree with. Yeah, that you're like, how do I get behind this? I don't know how to wrap my head around it. And Greg said something similar, which is that Jenna wouldn't like this, but Pam does. And very similarly, Jenna does not like being tickled, but Pam seemed to respond well to it. When Roy tickles her, she would always, like, come around, she liked being tickled.
所有看剧的观众也都会想：对啊，这到底是怎么回事？对。然后就是一个非常甜蜜、感人的时刻，你说：我喜欢。你看这个。就像，我根本不在乎别的什么乱七八糟的，但你给我买了房，你知道吗？你给我买了一栋房子。这太神奇了。所以我觉得，你可以从两个角度来看待这件事。比如，在我的现实生活中，我可不希望别人这么干。但同时这也取决于具体情况、当事人、你的生活以及事情本身，你知道的。而且我觉得，在这之前发生的事情是，罗伊（Roy）是个极其没有承诺感的人。他们订婚了那么长时间。然后你遇到了我们。然后你遇到了全心投入的吉姆。对。那种感觉一定棒极了。对。确实如此，真的。而且是一个从来没为帕姆做过任何事的男人。所以就会觉得，好吧，也许它走得太极端了，甚至可能有点过火。但它和她以往经历的一切完全不同，所以这样做真的非常感人，你知道的，这很甜蜜。
And I was like, but this one's really different. for me because I have a physical, like, visceral response to tickling that just causes sort of rage. Oh, my God. Dude, my mother is over there. Is this true? I'm getting a thumbs up from your mom. I have to resist with all my might hitting the person. Yes. Yes. Thank you. I feel seen. Tickling is a serious thing. My brother tickled me. We were in anthropology when I was a little kid and my brother started tickling me and I had an overreaction to make him feel bad. I was like, oh my God, stop. And I like swung my whole body and I bonged myself on the corner of a table and gave myself a black eye. Oh no. And I always blamed him because he was tickling me. Did he ever tickle you again?
这很有趣，因为当那一集播出时，我说过——而且我们以前也讨论过这个问题——当剧本为你的角色写了某些内容时，你该怎么办？对。那些你不同意的。对，你会想：我怎么能接受这个？我不知道该怎么说服自己接受它。格雷格（Greg）说过类似的话，他说珍娜不会喜欢这个，但帕姆喜欢。非常相似的是，珍娜不喜欢别人挠痒痒，但帕姆似乎对此反应很好。当罗伊挠她痒痒时，她总是会……转过身去，她挺喜欢被挠痒痒的。
Yeah. Okay. He did. But he was scared to because I'd be like, I'll give myself a black eye and I'll blame it on you. Yeah. Older brother gets the punishment. But no, I agree that I'd be furious if somebody bought a house and didn't ask me or tell me. Yeah. Be furious. Jenna wouldn't like that. Yeah. But then it's also like funny when you sell the house.
而我说：但这个对我来说真的很不一样，因为我对挠痒痒有一种身体上的、本能的反应，那只会引发某种狂怒。哦，天哪。老兄，我妈妈就在那边。这是真的吗？我得到了你妈妈的竖大拇指。我必须用尽全力去克制自己，才不会揍那个人。是的。是的。谢谢。我感觉被理解了。挠痒痒是一件很严肃的事。我哥哥挠我痒痒。我们小的时候在人类学博物馆，我哥哥开始挠我痒痒，为了让他感到内疚，我做出了过激的反应。我当时说：哦，天哪，停下。然后我整个身体猛地一甩，一头撞在桌子角上，给自己弄了个黑眼圈。哦，不。我一直怪他，因为是他挠我痒痒。他后来还挠过你吗？
I'm telling him absolutely bonkers if that happens. But it's like you have a point. You're like, well, you bought it without telling me. So I thought I could sell it without telling you. Every time I hear that line, I'm like, unbelievable. I know. You bought the house without telling me. So I'm like, sell it.
对。好吧。他挠过。但他很害怕，因为我会说：我会给自己弄个黑眼圈，然后怪到你头上。对。哥哥承担惩罚。不过说真的，我同意如果有人不跟我商量或告诉我、自己买了一栋房子，我会气炸的。对。绝对会气炸。珍娜不会喜欢那样。对。但随后当你卖掉这栋房子时，又觉得挺搞笑的。
I know. It's a weird bookin. It's a crazy relationship. Maybe she had been holding on to it a little bit. I don't know. Clearly, yeah. Clearly. I mean, every week I had to, like, reconcile with a character that was very different from me.
如果发生这种事，我绝对会告诉他这太离谱了。但你就觉得挺有道理的。你会想：好吧，你买它的时候没告诉我。所以我想我卖它的时候也可以不告诉你。每次听到那句台词，我都觉得：难以置信。我知道。你买这栋房子都没告诉我。所以我决定：把它卖了。
Like, oh, yeah. All of my reactions, everything. So I can really relate to that. I mean, there were plenty of times where I was like, okay, can we dial Angela back just a little? Like, can she not always just be the bitch? And I loved that note that Ken Kwapis gave me. He was like, Angela, today, why don't you try being the suspicious bitch? And I was like, ooh, she's totally different than like the strict bitch, suspicious bitch.
我知道。这是个奇怪的伏笔。这是一种疯狂的关系。也许她心里一直有点芥蒂吧。我不知道。显然是的。显然是的。我是说，每个星期我都必须跟一个与我本人截然不同的角色达成和解。
Was there anything in Angela's character that you did, like, resonate with at all? I mean, I do love animals. I mean, I don't know. I haven't ever licked my cat. I did really do that, Billy. Yeah, I was going to ask. I really licked it. I love that you did.
比如，哦，是的。我所有的反应，我的一言一行。所以我对此真的感同身受。我是说，有很多次我都想：好吧，我们能不能把安吉拉这个角色稍微收敛一点点？比如，她能不能别总是那么尖酸刻薄？我非常喜欢肯·夸皮斯（Ken Kwapis）给我的那个指导。他说：安吉拉，今天，你为什么不试着做一个多疑的碧池呢？我当时就想：哦，这和严厉的碧池完全不同，是个多疑的碧池。
I mean, they were like, it's just one take. Just one take, we're going to be a little bit closer. And I was like, oh, and then. I licked the cat. But I also like Angela. She's, once she's in, she's very loyal. Like, you know, like, I don't think she ever gave up on Dwight, even though they were such a weird on and off again romance.
安吉拉这个角色身上，有没有哪一点是你多多少少能产生共鸣的？我是说，我很喜欢动物。我是说，我不知道。我从来没有舔过我的猫。我真的那样做过，比利（Billy）。对，我正要问呢。我真的舔了。我很高兴你这么做了。
But he was her soup snake, you know? It's true. So I guess those two things, but pretty much nothing else. If you were an office character, which one would you be? Good one. I've always really resonated with Michael's character, which is maybe problematic. I just, and I've said that before to like my mom or like my parents and my brother and stuff. But it's really true.
我是说，他们当时说：就拍一条。就拍一条，我们会拍得离近一点。然后我就想：哦，然后。我就舔了那只猫。但我其实也挺喜欢安吉拉的。她这个人，一旦她认定了一个人，就会非常忠诚。比如，你知道的，我觉得她从来没有对德怀特（Dwight）死心过，尽管他们之间的恋情分分合合，极其诡异。
I see a lot of my, this character and not some stuff, like more of just like, I can't even really explain it. There's just something that I really, really, really relate to about. his character. One of my favorite moments is when he can't help but shout, that's what she said. Even if he's like furious. Like when she
但他一直是她的“汤中蛇”（soup snake），你知道的。确实如此。所以我想大概就是这两点吧，除此之外几乎没有了。如果你是《办公室》里的一个角色，你会是哪一个？好问题。我一直对迈克尔这个角色非常有共鸣，这可能有点问题。我只是，我以前对我妈或者我爸妈还有我哥他们说过。但这是真的。
is this about to throw the dundee at the TV and they're having that argument and he's like so angry and he's clearly just so sad and like, you know. And then she's like you're hardly my first and he's so angry but he has this need
我在这个角色身上看到了很多自己的影子，也不是所有方面，更多的是一种……我甚至无法真正解释。就是有什么东西让我对他的角色产生了非常非常强烈的共鸣。我最喜欢的时刻之一，就是他忍不住大喊“这就是她说的”（That's what she said）。哪怕他气得要死。比如当她
to say that's what she said because he know I need to say it, and he just shouts it at her. Michael also just has such a pure heart. He really does. I know. He's pretty, like, just a person who just wants love and to be loved, but he goes about it so wonky. But I'm with you.
正准备把邓迪奖杯（Dundee）扔向电视机，他们正在激烈争吵，他气得不行，而且显然伤心欲绝，你知道的。然后她来了一句“你才算不上我的第一个男人”，他气极败坏，但还是有这种强烈的冲动
Whenever he has to yell something, every time I lose it. Oh, it's so funny. I hadn't seen him yell. I declare bankruptcy until we rewatched it. Yeah. And just, like, his need to do that, to make this announcement is like, Amazing. It just hurts my soul how he's like, that's how he thinks you declare bankruptcy. You declare it out loud in a room. It's done. I've done it. I just feel that. Okay. And this is a part that I find. So starting to watch The Office at a really young age, I almost didn't understand any reference whatsoever. I just thought it was funny. And I thought, you know, it was, it was funny. I just liked the show in general. But a lot, most of the references, I had no idea who anybody was, no idea what movies they were referencing. So something I do blame the office for, to be honest, is – but then also I blame myself
去说出那句“这就是她说的”，因为他知道我必须说出来，然后他直接冲着她大喊。迈克尔其实也有一颗无比纯洁的心。他真的是。我知道。他其实就是……一个渴望爱与被爱的人，但他用的方式实在是太古怪了。不过我和你一样。
that I blame the office is – is there's so many things that are said, especially by Michael, in the office, that he says wrong on purpose, like written on purpose. Yeah. That I didn't even know the real word. So I said many words wrong because I learned them from Michael Scott. Were you a little stitious? I was a little – That one I knew.
每当他不得不大喊大叫的时候，我每一次都会笑崩。哦，太搞笑了。直到我们重温之前，我都没见过他大喊“我宣布破产”。对。而且，就好像他非得这么做不可，非得发表这个重大声明，简直……太神奇了。一想到他是这么理解如何宣布破产的，我的心就隐隐作痛。你就是在房间里大声宣布出来。这就完成了。我已经完成了。我真的有同感。好吧。而这正是我发现的一个部分。从小时候开始看《办公室》的时候，我几乎完全听不懂任何梗。我只觉得很好笑。而且我想，你知道，这挺搞笑的。我只是单纯喜欢这部剧。但是很多，绝大多数的梗，我根本不知道谁是谁，也不知道他们在致敬哪些电影。所以，老实说，我把《办公室》当作一个借口——但同时我也怪我自己
That was one that I knew, and I was very proud that I knew that one. But like, insurmountable, to be honest. I thought that was a word. I thought, this has happened many times. I never thought about this filter of the office that on a younger person, they're learning Michael's vocabulary. Yes. Learning his vocabulary, because I thought I was learning new words. Oh, my God.
把这锅甩给《办公室》——那就是有很多台词，尤其是迈克尔在《办公室》里说的那些，他是故意说错的，就好像剧本是故意写错的一样。对。以至于我连真正的单词是什么都不知道。所以我说错了很多词，因为我是从迈克尔·斯科特那里学来的。你以前也有点“迷信”（little stitious）吗？我有点……那个词我知道。
Which I was. They were just wrong. And then same when, you know, the joke when Aaron is like, my New Year's resolution was to learn a new word every day. Yeah. And it is going immensely. Yeah. I didn't get that. I was like, oh, cool.
那个词我知道，而且我为自己知道那个词感到非常骄傲。但比如“不可逾越”（insurmountable），说实话。我以前以为那是个词。我想，这已经发生过很多次了。我从来没想过《办公室》对年轻观众的这种滤镜，让他们在潜移默化中学习迈克尔的词汇。是的。学习他的词汇，因为我以为自己在学新词。哦，天哪。
I'll start seeing that. So now, because I have said so many things wrong. Mom, do you remember off the top of your head some more ones that I just said that everyone was like, what the hell? I remember when you first heard that you two was from Ireland. Oh, you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys, you guys. What? Okay. This is, this is the worst one. Sweet, sweet Bono is a supporter of mine. Yeah. And I, I love him. My God. Amazing. Yeah. My God. Here's the issue, guys. What? What? Literally in June, this last June, we were in Ireland. So very recently, we were in Ireland. And I get, oh, God, I'm in my hotel.
我的确在学。只不过它们全都是错的。然后同样的，你知道那个笑话吗，当艾琳（Erin）说：我新年的决心是每天学一个新词。对。而且进展极其顺利。对。我当时没听懂。我当时想：哦，酷。
And I get flowers delivered to my hotel room and it has a little letter on it. And it's this really, really sweet letter and it says from Bono. And I was like, why would Bono, who's from Scranton? You thought Bono was from Scranton, Pennsylvania? I go, why would he send me something in Ireland? What does this have to do with him? And it was like welcome to, like, it was something about like welcome to my like hometown or something. like that. But you two is from Scranton. And I was like, I kept asking everyone like, what was, what is, what is, what is
我也要开始这么做。所以现在，因为我说错过太多东西了。妈妈，你脑子里还能随口说出其他几个我刚才随口一说、惹得所有人都在想“这到底是什么鬼”的词吗？我还记得你第一次听说U2乐队来自爱尔兰的时候。哦，你们，你们，你们，你们，你们，你们，你们，你们，你们。什么？好吧。这是，这是最糟糕的一个。亲爱的，亲爱的博诺（Bono）是我的支持者。对。而且，我爱他。天哪。太神奇了。对。天哪。问题在这儿呢，伙计们。什么？什么？ literalmente在六月份，就在今年六月份，我们在爱尔兰。所以非常不久前，我们在爱尔兰。然后我接到，哦，天哪，我在酒店里。
doing sending me flowers all the way across the world? From Scrant. Why would he do that? What is, what does this have to do with anything? And they were like, Billy, what are you talking about? They're Irish. I was like, no, they're not. Have you, have you told him this story yet? No. Oh, my God. But it's because when, when Michael falls in love with Holly and he's making her a mix and, freak, I, blame John for this because Jim comes in and Michael goes, what's the band from Scranton that made it big? Is that you too? And Jim goes, yes. And then he sits down and he goes, you don't love Holly. That's all there is. It's not even, there's no pause. There's no laugh. But if you've seen it 30 times, then guess what? You too is from Scranton. I thought it was like, honestly,
然后有人把花送到我的酒店房间，上面有一封短信。那是一封非常非常甜的信，上面写着来自博诺。我当时想：为什么博诺会从斯克兰顿（Scranton）……你以为博诺来自宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿？我说：他为什么要在爱尔兰给我送东西？这跟他有什么关系？而且上面写着欢迎来到，就像是什么欢迎来到我的家乡之类的话。但是U2乐队来自斯克兰顿。然后我就一直问每个人：到底是怎么回事，这是在干什么，
in my head, I thought, Jim thought, oh, that's a stupid question because obviously they're the band that made it big from Scranton. I thought if it was like, I thought it was like the question like, is, you know, oh, I don't even know, like, is, like, is so and so that's very obviously from this place. Yeah. Are they from that place? You're like, yeah, obviously. I thought that was the vibe. Instead of no, not at all, their whole thing instead of. This is in June. June. I didn't know. Like, I could have been in an interview. Somebody could have asked me about what you do in Bono. And I could. Okay. Well, it's really cool because here's the thing. Here's the thing. We are going to give you our phone numbers. Anytime you come up on something like, is this? Just text us. We're like you're up. Yeah, I'm going to need to do that.
为什么他要大老远把花送到世界另一头？来自斯克兰顿。他为什么要这么做？这到底跟什么有关系？然后他们说：比利，你在说什么啊？他们是爱尔兰人。我说：不，才不是。你们，你们把这个故事告诉他了吗？还没有。哦，天哪。但这全是因为，当迈克尔爱上霍莉（Holly）并为她制作混音带时，天哪，我得怪约翰（John），因为吉姆走进来，迈克尔说：斯克兰顿那个红了的乐队叫什么来着？是U2吗？然后吉姆说：是的。接着他坐下来，说道：你根本不爱霍莉。就这样。甚至没有停顿。没有笑声。但如果你看过30遍，那么你猜怎么着？U2就是来自斯克兰顿的。我当时真的觉得，
How much do you watch The Office? Because I read in an interview that it's like all the time. Okay. So I play it. It's playing only. on my phone. I don't watch it on anything else. It's playing on my phone at all times when I'm doing anything. When I'm like in the shower, I have it sitting outside the shower. I can't have any silence, guys. It's like right outside the shower. It's like when I'm getting dressed, when I'm eating food, when I put on makeup, when I do my hair, when I, like, it's like truly playing always just in my hair. Like I'll just, honestly, I'll be, I was like rearranging my closet a couple months ago or maybe longer ago, and it was just in my pocket. I couldn't even see it. It was just in my pocket
在我的脑子里，我以为，吉姆当时在想：哦，这是一个很蠢的问题，因为他们显然是从斯克兰顿红出来的乐队。我以为这就好比是一个问题，比如，你知道的，哦，我都不知道怎么说，比如，某某人显然来自这个地方。对。他们是不是来自那个地方？你会觉得：对，显然是。我当时以为那是这种氛围。而不是说：不，完全不是，他们的全部背景其实是……这是在六月份。六月份。我当时根本不知道。我当时甚至可能会去接受采访。别人可能会问我关于U2和博诺的事，而我完全可以……好吧，这真的很酷，因为事情是这样的。事情是这样的。我们要把电话号码留给你。以后你遇到类似“这是真的吗”之类的情况。直接给我们发信息。我们就当你的场外求助。对，我以后确实需要这样。
and the audio was playing. And it's like, I listened to it like it's a podcast. Also, because I've seen it so many times, I have it all memorized, like all the lines memorized, and all the visuals memorized, so I can picture it. I don't, I'm not missing. You don't even need to look at it. I don't even need to look at it. This makes something your mom said to me when we met when you got here make perfect sense. Maggie said to me, I feel like I know you guys because I hear your voices all the time. And I thought, well, all the time? All the time. And, you know, I don't live at home anymore, but when I lived at home, it was, I mean, it's just, it's just, you can just hear it. And I also have like weird needs. Again, I have these weird, I have like a need to like, if I'm eating, I have to have the office playing or something playing, preferably the office and silence otherwise. Like nobody, if you talk to me, I'm not there. I'm not there. And so, but when I was living at home, I'd be like, go. going into my parents' kitchen, where my parents were, and being like, shh, turning on the office
你到底有多爱看《办公室》？因为我从一篇采访里看到，你简直是无时无刻不在看。好吧。所以我一直放着它。它只在我的手机上播放。我不用其他任何设备看。在我做任何事情的时候，它都一直在我的手机上播放。比如我在洗澡的时候，我会把它放在浴室外面。伙计们，我一秒钟都不能忍受安静。它就在浴室外面。比如当我穿衣服的时候、当我吃东西的时候、当我化妆的时候、当我弄头发的时候、当我……就像是，它真的永远都在我的头脑里播放。就像我，说实话，我几个月前在整理衣柜的时候，或者更久之前，它就塞在我的口袋里。我都看不到屏幕。它就塞在口袋里
and being like, don't talk to me. I'm watching the office. I'm eating my waffles. Leave me alone. Maggie, we love you. We love you guys. Parents are amazing. Okay.
然后放着音频。而且就好像，我把它当成播客来听。另外，因为我看过太多遍了，我把所有的台词都背下来了，所有的画面也都背下来了，所以我能在脑海里想象出画面。我不需要……你甚至不需要看。我甚至都不需要看。这让我妈妈之前见你时对我说的话变得完全合情合理了。玛吉（Maggie）对我说：我觉得我认识你们，因为我一直都能听到你们的声音。我当时想，真的假的？无时无刻。而且，你知道的，我不再跟父母同住了，但当我跟他们住在一起时，我的意思是，它就是……你到处都能听到声音。而且我还有点奇怪的需求。再说一次，我有一些奇怪的需求，比如如果我在吃饭，我必须放着《办公室》或者其他什么节目，最好是《办公室》，否则就是死一般的寂静。否则任何人，如果你跟我说话，我都不在那里。我不在状态。所以，但是当我住在家里时，我会……走进我爸妈的厨房，我爸妈正在那儿，然后说：嘘，打开《办公室》，
Oh, actually, Jenna, I'm curious. So you're Michael Scott, right, Billy. Which office character are you? Me? Who am I most like? Yeah. Ooh. So I'm most like Pam.
然后说：别跟我说话。我在看《办公室》。我在吃华夫饼。别理我。玛吉，我们爱你。我们爱你们。父母太棒了。好吧。
Like, there was so much of me that was Pam. that was Pam and so much of my early life as a struggling actress that I brought to Pam. I mean, I literally know what it feels like to sit at a reception desk and wish that I had an artistic career because I was a receptionist. So I know that longing and I know that feeling of wanting something to change, but feeling like I'm in a place where nothing ever changes. So I definitely could relate to that, but I am an action person. So I am not a wait for it to come to me person. And I feel like Pam, it was harder for her to get herself started or take movement, you know? So I'm just much more ambitious than Pam. I always say it would not take, it would not have taken me like three years
哦，实际上，珍娜，我挺好奇的。所以你是迈克尔·斯科特，对吧，比利。你是《办公室》里的哪个角色？我？我最像谁？对。哦。其实我最像帕姆。
to kiss the cutie in the office. Right. We're not waiting that long for that. Like that's happening much sooner. Would have happened at the Dundees, probably, if I were in charge. Like, for Reels, though, you know, not the not the drunken, not the falling onto his lips kiss, yeah. But I also think I have a tiny bit of Ryan and me. I have a lot of...
就像，我身上有太多帕姆的影子。那全都是帕姆的特质，而且我把我早期作为一个苦苦挣扎的女演员的很多经历都带入了帕姆这个角色。我是说，我真的知道坐在前台接待处、幻想着自己能拥有一个艺术职业是什么感觉，因为我曾经就是一个前台接待员。所以我懂那种渴望，我也懂那种想要改变现状、却又觉得自己身处一个永远不会有任何改变的地方的感觉。所以我绝对能对此感同身受，但我是一个行动派。所以我绝不是那种“守株待兔”等着机会找上门的人。我觉得对帕姆来说，要迈出第一步或者采取行动要难得多，你知道吗？所以我比帕姆要有野心得多。我总是说，如果换作是我，绝对不会花整整三年时间
She is falling. She loves Ryan now. I have fallen in love with Ryan on this rewatch. Which version of him? There's serious different versions. Talk about so many versions of a character. Those are like, it's like he's playing different characters. I think my favorite is Ryan the temp. So I
去亲吻办公室里的那个大帅哥。对吧。我们可不会等那么久。那种事会发生得早得多。我要是负责人，可能在邓迪奖派对上就发生了。我是说真的，不是那种醉醺醺的，不是那种不小心摔倒在他嘴唇上的吻，对吧。但我也觉得我内心深处有一点点瑞安（Ryan）的影子。我有很多……
Like early Ryan, but I guess it's just, I have a lot of entrepreneurial ideas that go nowhere. You know, gadgets that I've invented in my mind and things that, you know, never get made and whatever. We've discussed on the podcast before that with my high school best friend, we invented something called the tan baster. It is a way to put on a sun tanning lotion without getting your hands dirty. It's called the tan baster. You know the thing that you wash dishes with that, like, fills with dish soap and then has a sponge on the end? Yes. So it's very similar, but with suntan lotion. And then you can also get the middle of your back with it. You know what I'm saying? The tan baster. I know. Bless your heart. The tan baster. Someday, I need you. Why are you going on HDTV?
她现在沦陷了。她现在爱上瑞安了。我在重温这部剧时爱上了瑞安。哪个版本的他？这里面有好几个完全不同的版本。说到一个角色的各种不同版本。那感觉就好像他演的是完全不同的人。我想我最喜欢的是实习生时期的瑞安。所以我
I don't know. I mean, I think I should call my friend and we should get it going again. Welcome to Celebrity Shark Tank. Today we have Jenna Fisher. Can you imagine you're so humiliating? You should do it. You're really passionate about it. You're so passionate, man. You just described it for so long. But what do you think? What's your honest opinion?
喜欢早期的瑞安，但我想，主要还是因为我有很多最终都泡汤的创业点子。你知道的，那些我在脑海里发明的各种小玩意儿，以及那些从来没有被真正制造出来的事情，诸如此类。我们以前在播客里讨论过，我和我高中最好的朋友曾发明过一种叫作“助晒棒”（the tan baster）的东西。这是一种涂抹防晒霜而不用弄脏双手的工具。它叫作“助晒棒”。你知道那种洗碗用的海绵刷吗，就是可以把洗洁精灌进去，然后前端带着海绵的那种？对。所以原理非常相似，只不过里面装的是防晒霜。然后你还可以用它来够到后背正中间。你们懂我在说什么吧？助晒棒。我知道。老天保佑你。助晒棒。总有一天，我需要你……你为什么要去上家居电视网（HGTV）？
I don't know. It's not happening, is it? Don't send me on shark tank. There's lots to be humiliated. There's lots of other inventions that do well that are stupider. Oh, my God. That's your. It's not a bad idea.
我不知道。我是说，我觉得我应该给我的朋友打电话，我们应该把它重新做起来。欢迎来到名人鲨鱼坦克（Celebrity Shark Tank）。今天我们有珍娜·费舍尔。你能想象吗，这太丢脸了。你应该去试试。你对它真的很有热情。你太有热情了，老兄。你刚才滔滔不绝讲了半天。但你怎么看？你有什么诚实的看法？
It's really not. I mean, I totally get it. like, you know, you get your hands all gross when you, I get it, especially at the beach and then you've got sand on your hands. I think you need to let it go. I think you need to let it go. One day, maybe. I'll have time. You know what? Tans are going to come back into fashion and when they do, I don't think tans are in fashion anymore. No, it's for the suntam lotion. It means sunscreen. The sunscreen, I'm sorry, yes. All of these years, you have told me about this. I thought it's like a spray tan and a tube. No, lady. It's a, and I think. And I thought,
我不知道。这根本行不通，对吧？别把我送去《鲨鱼坦克》。有很多能做得很成功的发明，其实比这个还要蠢得多。哦，天哪。那是你的……这其实不是个坏主意。
Applying sunscreen. I thought this is such an uneven tan. It looks like from a sponge. Well, that would be true if that's what it was for. Are you behind it now that you understand it? And sunscreen. I want you to go for this now. Applying sunscreen.
真的不是。我是说，我完全理解。就像，你知道的，你把防晒霜抹在手上，手就会变得黏糊糊的，我懂，尤其是去海滩的时候，手上还会沾满沙子。我觉得你应该放下这事了。我觉得你应该放下了。总有一天，也许吧。我会抽出时间的。你知道吗？美黑迟早会重新流行起来的，到时候，我不觉得美黑现在还流行。不，这是为了防晒霜。我是说防晒霜。防晒霜，对不起，是的。这么多年来，你一直跟我提起这个。我一直以为那是一个喷雾美黑乳液加一根管子。不，大姐。它是一个，而且我认为……
What about your face? It doesn't work on the face. No squeegey for the face. Well, we already have those like, you know, deodorant sticks that we can put on our face. The problem is that the rubbing in is where you distribute it evenly. And so that you actually get all the little cracks and crevices. Okay. All right.
涂抹防晒霜。我还以为这是一种涂出来很不均匀的美黑效果。看起来就像是用海绵擦出来的。好吧，如果那是它的用途，那确实如此。现在你明白了，你支持这个发明吗？还有防晒霜。我希望你现在全力支持这个。涂抹防晒霜。
You know what? Workshop. When we're testing that in our focus groups, we're going to think about that. We're going to make sure that we get a sponge that can apply evenly. So, Ryan, because of your ideas. Thank you for bringing us back. Sorry. Just had to come back.
你知道吗？工作坊。当我们在焦点小组测试时，我们会考虑到这一点。我们要确保买到能均匀涂抹的海绵。所以，瑞安，多亏了你的点子。谢谢你把我们带回来。抱歉。只是不得不回来。
Oh, my God. Ryan, because of your ideas, what about you? I think I'm a little, maybe a Phyllis Angela combo. platter, maybe a little bit. I'm a little bit, Angela. And then Phyllis has a little sauce. You know, she like hooked up with Bob Vance on the bathroom. She does. I have a little bit of that. Phyllis is a freak. A little bit. I might have a little bit of that combo in me. What do you think, Jenna? I think you are way more Phyllis than Angela. There's almost no Angela in Angela, except for maybe love of animals. But I think, yeah, I think Phyllis. I think
哦，天哪。瑞安，多亏了你的点子，你呢？我觉得我可能有点菲利斯和安吉拉的结合体。大拼盘，也许有一点。我有一点安吉拉的特质。然后菲利斯带点辣。你知道，她在浴室里跟鲍勃·万斯好过。她确实如此。我身上有一点那种特质。菲利斯是个怪咖。有一点。我身上可能有点那种组合。你觉得呢，珍娜？我觉得你比安吉拉更像菲利斯。安吉拉身上几乎没有安吉拉的影子，除了可能对动物的爱。但我觉得，是的，我觉得菲利斯。我觉得
Phyllis is a strong choice. Maybe with the side of Kelly, like chatty Kelly. Yes, Angela's very chat. I do like to chat. Yeah, I get it. I feel that. I feel that for sure. Like, I could go to your family reunion and I wouldn't have a problem. I wouldn't miss the beat. Wow. I could go to your cousin's wedding. I'd have the time of my life. Well, I think that's also like you're a good hang. That's what that is also. Thanks, Billy. That's a good thing. Oh my gosh. When you can just bit right in anywhere, you're good. Oh, oh, oh, oh, I have a thing. What is it? Okay. Okay. I just got very excited about this. So, How many cast members have you met from the office? So I've met Creed. Yes. I've met Rain. Mm-hmm. You know what's interesting? I've spoken on the phone with Steve and...
菲利斯是个很强烈的选择。也许带点凯利的特质，像爱聊天的凯利。是的，安吉拉其实挺爱聊的。我确实喜欢聊天。是的，我懂。我完全能理解。绝对能理解。比如，我去参加你们的家族聚会，我也不会觉得有什么问题。我能接上所有的话。哇。我可以去参加你表亲的婚礼。我会度过生命中最棒的一时。嗯，我觉得这也是因为你很会社交。这也就是那个意思。谢谢，比利。这是个夸奖。噢天哪。当你能自然而然地融入任何地方时，你就很棒。哦，哦，哦，哦，我有个事。是什么？好。好。我刚才对这个超级兴奋。所以，你们见过多少《办公室》的演员？所以我见过克里德。是的。我见过雷恩。嗯哼。你知道有趣的是什么吗？我在电话里和史蒂夫聊过，还有……
Brian. Yes, Brian. Yeah, that's right. Steve and Brian. I think that... Oh, I've met... I've met Mindy and I've met BJ. Mm-hmm.
布莱恩。是的，布莱恩。对，没错。史蒂夫和布莱恩。我觉得……噢，我见过……我见过敏迪，我还见过BJ。嗯哼。
Oh, well, actually, okay, so two interesting things. Mm-hmm. When I was a kid, I think I must have been, I'm four and a half years younger than my brother, and he was probably 13 or 14. So I was some years younger than that. My brother was in Bad Teacher, which is with Cameron Diaz. And I was like a little kid, and I remember going to hang out on set at one point and standing in craft services. And Phyllis was right there.
哦，其实，好吧，有两件有趣的事。嗯哼。当我还是个孩子的时候，我想我大概，我比我哥哥小四岁半，他可能13或14岁。所以我比那个还要小几岁。我哥哥出演了《劣质师姐》，那是和卡梅隆·迪亚兹合作的。我还是个小孩子，我记得有一次去片场探班，站在道具餐饮区。菲利斯就在那里。
And I hadn't seen the office. I was like, I must have been like, you know, I was probably like eight or nine or something. And she was standing there and I remember somebody saying like, she's in the office. And I remember thinking, the office, like, I know that show. That's really cool. I've never seen it, but that's really cool. And I remember standing right next to her, like she was right here and she was eating chips or something and she was having a conversation with something. And I just remember looking up at her and being like, she's a star.
我当时还没看过《办公室》。我当时大概，你知道，我大概八九岁左右。她就站在那儿，我记得有人说，她演了《办公室》。我当时想，《办公室》？我知道那个节目。太酷了。我从没看过，但那真的很酷。我记得我就站在她旁边，她就在这儿，好像在吃薯片什么的，正在跟人聊天。我只记得抬头看着她，心里想，她是个明星。
And she doesn't know that. I don't think I've ever spoken to her. That was like a big deal for me. I talked about that for a long time after. And she has no idea that that little kid was me also. And then the other thing is my mom's, one of my mom's long-lasting best friends is Amy Ryan. Oh my gosh. So I grew up around Amy.
她不知道这件事。我想我从来没跟她说过。这对当时的我来说是一件大事。我在那之后很久还一直在谈论这件事。而她完全不知道那个小孩子也是我。然后另一件事是我妈妈的，我妈妈的一个多年挚友是艾米·瑞安。噢天哪。所以我是在艾米身边长大的。
Yeah. And so, you know, I knew her, we knew her like before she was obviously. cast. Yeah. And, um, and then she was just like one of my mom's friends. And then she, uh, once I started being a fan of the office, it, it was hard for me to be around her. It was, I was, because she was Holly. She was Holly. Right then, too. And I was like, I was like, peak the office was, was it. It was, it was, it was, yeah. So she, she has been in my life for a long time and she has a daughter who's a few years younger than me and I we would we would uh go to their house and like I'd play with her daughter and it was cool yeah she's she's great I love her
是的。所以，你知道，我认识她，我们在她出名前就认识她了。是的，而且，嗯，她当时就像是我妈妈的一个朋友。然后她，呃，一旦我开始成为《办公室》的粉丝，我就很难和她相处了。这真的，因为她是霍莉。她就是霍莉。当时也是这样。我当时就觉得，我当时觉得《办公室》正处于巅峰时期。就是这样。就是这样，就是这样，就是这样，对。所以她，她走进我的生活很久了，她有个女儿比我小几岁，我们就会，我们会去他们家，我就会跟她的女儿玩，这很酷，是的，她，她很好，我爱她。
she's she's great I love Amy hearing that Amy is amazing you know it's interesting because my daughter one of my daughter's friends recently started watching the office I have known this little girl they're 14 now I've known her since kindergarten right best friends since kindergarten she was over at the house the other day and she was like looking at me like this like oh my god and i was like i turned around i was like what's that what's going on she's like sorry i started watching the office oh my god i was like i have known you forever but now i'm angela martin you know and i'm like oh my gosh it's so funny you know what the other one was i i used to be a camp counselor and there was this girl and she was like my favorite student at
她，她很好，我爱艾米。听到艾米这么棒，你知道这很有趣，因为我女儿，我女儿的一个朋友最近开始看《办公室》。我认识这个小女孩，她们现在14岁了。我从幼儿园就认识她了，对吧？从幼儿园开始就是最好的朋友。她前几天来我家，她看着我，眼神是这样的，就像“哦，天哪”。然后我转过身去，问：“怎么了？发生什么事了？”她说：“对不起，我开始看《办公室》了。”哦，天哪，我说：“我认识你这么久了，但现在我是安吉拉·马丁了。”你知道，我心想：“哦，天哪，太搞笑了。”你知道另一个是什么吗？我以前是个夏令营辅导员，有个女孩，她就像是我在营里最喜欢的学生
the camp and her name was piper and i loved her to pieces and her mom would come to her every day and I was like, that's Jan. That's literally Jan. And I was like, is your mom Jan? And she was like, yeah. Oh my gosh. That is crazy. That's so cool. It's Jan. And I tried not to freak her out because I'm sure she was annoyed with that a lot. But I think about her a lot. I hope she's doing well. Okay, I have a message for you from Creed. Okay, so Creed is my neighbor. Really? Yeah, he lives down the street from me. No way. Walking distance. Yeah. Like we, we, sometimes we walk, we call it the sauce trail. We get an adult beverage and a red solo cup and we go for a walk. And he often comes over and brings his guitar and like jams out. He'll be like, Angie, I have a new album. You want to hear it? I'm like, yes. It's like one of the joys of my life. But he, we were texting because he loves animal documentaries and he was texting me recently that he wants me to come watch one. And I said, hey, I said, have you met Billy Eilis? She's coming into the studio. We're so excited. And he wrote back and he said, yes, I have. I met her brother also. She's been ghosting me for a while.
她的名字叫派珀，我极其喜爱她。她妈妈每天都会来看她，我当时想，那是简。那简直就是简。我就问：“你妈妈是简吗？”她说：“对啊。”哦，天哪。太疯狂了。太酷了。那是简。我尽量不去吓到她，因为我确信她对这种事已经感到厌烦了。但我经常想起她。希望她过得好。好吧，我这里有克里德给你的一个口信。好的，克里德是我的邻居。真的吗？对，他就住在离我这条街不远的地方。不会吧。步行距离。对。我们，我们，有时我们会散步，我们称之为“沙司小径”。我们拿一杯成人饮料和一个红色的塑料杯，然后出去散步。他经常过来，带着他的吉他，然后即兴弹奏。他会说：“安吉，我有一张新专辑。你想听吗？”我说：“好啊。”这就像是我生活中的乐趣之一。但他，我们当时在发短信，因为他喜欢动物纪录片，他最近发短信给我说他想让我去看一部。我说：“嘿，我说，你见过比利·艾利什吗？她要来录音室了。我们好兴奋。”他回信说：“是的，我见过。我也见过她哥哥。她已经晾了我好一会儿了。”
And then he called me and he said, I'm kidding, Pumpkin. I'm kidding. And I said, I figured you were kidding. And he said, I was blown away by her voice. I got to see her in concert. She's amazing. I loved meeting Phineas too. And will you tell her that if she ever wants to talk music or jam to come over, I'm around? Yeah. Oh, that's sweet. I know. I met a. for like a split second. He came to one of my shows like three and a half years ago. And I was meeting million people and I was like, it's fucking great. I went over and I looked at him. It was really cool. But you know what's funny about like, I love that his just all of his musical talent just comes through throughout the show. And what I think is really cool is, you know, when he's singing spinning and reeling with love at the Christmas party, when everybody's doing characters, I love that that's in there because it's his song, but you don't know that, and you think he's just, honestly, because here's one more thing, is that I watch that thinking, this is probably a super famous song. Everybody knows, and he's doing a karaoke to it. And I always thought the song was really cool. And I find a lot of the music that I love through other things and like hearing in the background of something and looking up the lyrics. And so I remember after a while being like, every time I watch that scene, I'm always like, oh, that song is really cool.
然后他给我打电话说：“我开玩笑的，小南瓜。我开玩笑的。”我说：“我猜你就是开玩笑。”他说：“她的声音把我惊艳到了。我去看过她的演唱会。她太棒了。我也很喜欢见到菲尼亚斯。你能告诉她，如果她想聊音乐或者即兴合奏，随时过来，我都在吗？”好啊，太贴心了。我知道。我见 A. 也就是呆了一秒钟。他大约三年半前来看过我的一场演出。当时我在见上百万人，我说：“这他妈太棒了。”我走过去看了他一眼。这真的很酷。但你知道关于什么很有趣吗，我喜欢他所有的音乐才华在整部剧中自然流露。我觉得真的很酷的是，你知道的，当他在圣诞派对上每个人都在扮演角色时，深情地唱着《旋转与摇摆》，我很高兴那首歌被收录进去，因为那是他的歌，但你不知道这一点，你以为他只是，老实说，因为还有一件事，我看着那个场景心想，这可能是一首超级著名的歌。每个人都知道，他只是在唱卡拉OK。我一直觉得这首歌真的很酷。我通过其他事情发现了许多我喜爱的音乐，比如听到某首歌曲的背景音乐然后去查歌词。所以我记得过了一段时间后，每次我看那个场景，我都总是觉得，哦，这首歌真的很酷。
I love whatever song this is. What song is this? And I looked it up, honestly, probably like last year. And I saw that it was his song. And I was like, he's a great songwriter. He will just come over and play. And I mean, I'm always amazed. I'm amazed when I love to write, but it's always so interesting for me when people can put music to words because I can't hear music. That's such a gift. Like maybe it's maybe. Maybe. Maybe. some in another life, I'll get to hear music in my head like that, because that is so cool. And if you can't hear it, when you see people who can, it's like you're a little piece of magic that you get to witness. It's like so cool. Yeah, I'm the same way. My son is a musician. He's drummer and plays guitar. And from the time he was very little, he would be like three years old. We'd be driving somewhere. And from the backseat, he would say with his little voice, Mama, you play a song with a lot of ride symbol. Play a song with a lot of ride symbol.
我喜欢这不管是什么歌。这到底是什么歌？老实说，我大概去年查了一下。我发现那是他的歌。我当时想，他是个很棒的词曲创作者。他就会直接过来弹奏。我的意思是，我总是感到惊讶。我很惊讶，我喜欢写作，但每当人们能把音乐和文字结合起来时，对我来说总是非常有趣，因为我听不到音乐。这真是一种天赋。也许是，也许。也许。也许在另一生中，我能在脑海里像那样听到音乐，因为那太酷了。如果你听不到，当你看到能听到的人时，就像是你亲眼见证了一点点魔法。这简直太酷了。是的，我也是这样。我儿子是个音乐家。他是个鼓手，还会弹吉他。从他很小的时候起，大概三岁左右。我们开车去某个地方。坐在后座上，他会用稚嫩的声音说：“妈妈，放一首有很多骑镲的歌。放一首有很多骑镲的歌。”
And I would say, and I said, baby, I don't know what song has a lot of ride symbol in it. And then he, I mean, I'm going to get it wrong, but then he would say like some Green Day song. Right. And then I'd put it on and I'd be like, holy shit, there's a lot of ride symbol in this song. Wow. And so it is true because I'm seeing. that in my own house with this person who can, like, hear music in a way that I just, you know, it's so specific.
然后我会说，我说：“宝贝，我不知道哪首歌里有很多骑镲。”然后他，我的意思是我可能会记错，但接着他会说出某首绿日乐队的歌。没错。然后我把它放出来，心想：“靠，这首歌里真的有很多骑镲。”哇。所以这是真的，因为我在我自己的家里，在这个人身上看到了这一点，他能以一种我只是，你知道，如此具体的方式听到音乐。
It's so interesting hearing that you guys can't. Have you ever tried to write a song? No, I haven't. No, I haven't. I mean, I've written poetry and I've written, you know, I was a English, I was a creative writing major, but I don't know that I can see it. Well, this is actually a great segue into my next question, which is that you sampled part of the episode, Threat Level Midnight. I did.
听到你们听不到，真的很有趣。你们试过写歌吗？不，我没有。不，我没有。我是说，我写过诗，我写过，你知道，我以前是个英语，我以前是个创意写作专业，但我不知道我能不能看出来。好吧，这实际上很好地过渡到了我的下一个问题，那就是你们采样了《危险边缘：午夜威胁》这一集的部分内容。我确实采样了。
For your song, My Strange Addiction. I did. How did that come about? Well, first of all, I can't believe they let me do that because that's, I mean, that's wild to do that. Like, take audio from a show like The Office that's that big and that. I mean, come on. It was crazy. It was such a pipe dream.
为了你的歌《我的奇怪癖好》。我确实这么做了。那是怎么实现的？嗯，首先，我简直不敢相信他们让我这么做，因为这，我的意思是，这么做太疯狂了。比如从像《办公室》这样体量巨大且这样的节目里截取音频。我的意思是，拜托。太疯狂了。那简直是一个遥不可及的梦想。
I can't even tell you. It was wild that they said. yes, because we are now, we're going back now through emails from NBC and standards and practices and things like that, and they were super particular. They were. Yeah. But I remember all of the people whose voices you hear, like Brian Baumgartner's on there and at home. You hear Mindy, you hear John. I remember, I think you hear BJ, right? Yep. So I remember, and Steve, I remember each of those individuals had to give permission. Yes, they did. They were enthusiastic. Yes. Yeah.
我甚至无法向你形容。他们居然答应了，这真是太疯狂了，因为我们现在，我们正在通过电子邮件查看来自NBC以及标准与实践部门等的邮件，他们超级挑剔。他们确实很挑剔。是的。但我记得你听到的每一个声音的主人，比如布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳就在里面，还有在家里。你听到敏迪的声音，你听到约翰的声音。我记得，我想你听到了BJ的声音，对吧？没错。所以我记得，还有史蒂夫，我记得每一个这样的人都必须给予许可。是的，他们确实同意了。他们非常热情。是的。对。
So they were, it was a, let me tell you, the office text thread blew up. Oh, yeah. When that went out. Like, everyone was so excited. Yeah. Oh, my God. It was very, very cool. I mean, so the way that that happened was Phineas, my brother, had written this song called My Strange Addiction, just the words and, like, the whole song.
所以他们，那是个，我告诉你，《办公室》的群聊直接炸锅了。哦，是的。当那首歌发布的时候。就像，每个人都超级兴奋。是的。哦，天哪。非常，非常酷。我的意思是，事情的经过是这样的，菲尼亚斯，我的哥哥，写了一首名为《我的奇怪癖好》的歌，只有歌词以及，整首歌。
And he was like, Billy, I wrote this song, like, do you think it's cool? And he played it for me, and he had this beat to it that was, like, so good. And I was like, dude, this reminds me of the song that they dance to. The scar. This reminds me of the scar. And he was like, what do you talk about? And I played the scene. And it just, just when he hits that button in the jukebox and it's like, it's like, it's so like, it's so stupid, but it's so good. I was like, this is giving me that same feeling of like dumb, but kind of groovy as shit. And so we were like, Oh, my God, that would be so... And also, the song is, it's, you know, kind of a playoff of, you know, the show, My Strange Addiction. Do you guys know that show? And it's about people with these weird addictions to, like, weird stuff.
然后他就说，比利，我写了这首歌，你觉得怎么样？然后他放给我听，里面有个节奏，真的太棒了。然后我说，老兄，这让我想起他们跳舞的那首歌。那个伤疤。这让我想起那个伤疤。然后他说，你在说什么？我就把那个场景放给他看。就在他按下点唱机那个按钮的时候，感觉就像是，太傻了，但又太棒了。我就觉得，这给了我那种又蠢又带感的感觉。所以我们就想，哦，天哪，那会太……而且，这首歌，你知道的，有点像是对那个节目《我的诡异癖好》的致敬。你们知道那个节目吗？就是讲人们对一些奇怪的东西有奇怪的癖好。
You know, Phineas wrote the song, but it's kind of about, like, you know, I've got an addiction, but it's to you. But I kind of was like, well, the office is also my addiction. Your addiction, yeah. And this song is kind of goofy, and it reminds me of that scene. And also, then we were just watching the scene, and it's like, the way that Andy's voice sounds and the way that Steve is just it's just the whole all the dialogue is so good and we were like dude what and we jokingly truly truly truly
你知道的，菲尼亚斯写了这首歌，但它其实是关于，你知道的，我有一种癖好，但对象是你。但我也觉得，办公室也是我的癖好。你的癖好，对。这首歌有点滑稽，让我想起了那一幕。而且，后来我们看了那个场景，就是安迪的声音听起来的方式，还有史蒂夫的表现，所有的台词都太棒了，我们就想，老兄，什么情况？我们开玩笑地，真的，真的，真的
jokingly like ripped the audio and just put it in the song and it was so perfect because Andy's name is Billy yeah seen yeah so then it's like no Billy I haven't done that dance since my wife's dead and we were like oh that'd be so crazy because my name is Billy yeah yeah and so we like put it to the song and there was not any reality that it would work or like be okay. But we were like, this is so funny. And we like sent it to the label and we were like, dude, like, can you just ask somebody?
开玩笑地把音频截下来，直接放进了歌里，这简直太完美了，因为安迪的名字叫比利，对吧？那个场景，对吧？然后就变成，不，比利，自从我老婆死后我再没跳过那个舞。我们就想，哦，这太疯狂了，因为我的名字叫比利，对，对。所以我们把它加到音乐里，根本没有想过这能行通或者能被允许。但我们觉得，这太搞笑了。然后我们就把它发给唱片公司，说，老兄，能不能去问问别人？
We know it's going to be a no, but just ask somebody. There's no way they're going to give us the rights to this at all. No way. And it was like, yeah, absolutely they're not, but we'll ask, truly. And here we are. And then we did it. You did it. It's amazing.
我们知道肯定会被拒绝，但还是去问问别人吧。他们绝对不会把版权给我们的。绝对不可能。然后就变成了，是的，他们绝对不会，但我们会去问的，真的。然后我们就做到了。你们做到了。这太神奇了。
And it's really cute because, you know, the fans have that whole song memorized. And so when I do it live, they all shout all the parts. Oh, my gosh. Did they do their... I love Ed Holmes does a lot of great characters. You know, he's so funny like that. So good. And I loved Ed as Andy, Andy's version of what he thought that bartender was.
而且真的很可爱，你知道的，粉丝们把整首歌都背下来了。所以当我现场演唱时，他们会把所有部分都喊出来。哦，天哪。他们会做那个……我特别喜欢埃德·霍姆斯，他演过很多出色的角色。你知道的，他就是这么搞笑。太棒了。我太喜欢埃德演的安迪了，安迪心目中那个酒保的形象。
Like, hey, you, you know. Yeah. Yeah, it's so good. Oh, it's so good, guys. Guys, I just love this. We're having the best time. I know. I'm just like, I feel like I'm going to have sore cheeks because I'm spalling so much.
就像，嘿，你，你知道的。对，对，太棒了。哦，太棒了，伙计们。伙计们，我太喜欢这个了。我们度过了最美好的时光。我懂的。我只是觉得，我脸颊都要笑酸了，因为我一直在大笑。
I know I feel the same. And I just, there's a lot of things that I love in the world and there's a lot of things that I'm passionate about. And I try not to be like a nerd about it. And truly, when I meet other people that like the office, I'm like, okay, whatever. Like, I don't care. I'm like, I'm not trying to relate to people about it because it's my own personal thing. And in my head, no one else knows the office except me.
我知道，我有同感。而且，世界上有很多我热爱的事物，也有很多我充满激情的事物。我尽量不表现得像个书呆子。说实话，当我遇到其他喜欢《办公室》的人时，我会想，好吧，随便吧。就像，我不在乎。我会想，我才不想跟别人产生共鸣呢，因为这是我个人的东西。在我脑海里，除了我没人知道《办公室》。
It's my show. It's not, I'm not a, I'm not in a club of people. I'm not, I am very, I'm very pick me about it. I don't know if you guys know what that means, but I'm very, like, I'm very, like, no, no one's ever seen. It's like how you kind of, like, you joke about, like, your boyfriend and, no, he's never dated anybody, but me. Oh, right, right. The only reason he's ever been with. Right. That's how I feel. The office is like, it was made for you. Made for me. You guys shot for nine years, just for me. On your phone. Nobody's seen it before.
这是我的剧。我不是，我不是什么粉丝俱乐部的人。我不是，我对这事儿特别自私。我不知道你们懂不懂这个意思，但我就是那种，不，从来没人看过。就像你那种，开玩笑说，你的男朋友，不，他除了我没跟任何人约会过。哦，对，对。他是唯一一个。对，我就是这种感觉。《办公室》就像是，它是专门为你拍的。专门为我拍的。你们拍了九年，就是为了我。在你的手机上。从来没人看过。
Yeah. Yeah. On my phone. But, but truly, like, I don't, I don't really talk about it. Like, like, oh yeah, and my favorite show The Office, da, da, da, da. It's truly like such a deeper thing than that that when people are like so i heard your favorite show is the office i'm like don't say that it's it's somehow just sacred to me it's sacred it's like a yeah it's truly like a sacred part of of my personality and and so much of who i am and the things that i do and say and think like and also i just i base a lot of my life situations on tv shows like scenes from stuff and the amount of like one of my best friends many times earlier this year. We'd be like in a really deep conversation about like something really serious in my life. And I'd just take a pause and she'd be like, oh my God, I know
对。对。在我的手机上。但是，说实话，我真的不会经常谈起它。就像，哦对了，我最喜欢的剧是《办公室》，巴拉巴拉巴拉。这真的比那要深得多，当别人说，哦，我听说你最喜欢的剧是《办公室》时，我就想，别这么说，这对我来说某种程度上是神圣的。它是神圣的，就像是一个，是的，它真的是我性格中神圣的一部分，是我所做、所说、所想的事情中非常重要的一部分。而且，我也把很多生活中的情况建立在电视剧的基础上，比如某些场景。我的一个好朋友今年早些时候很多次，我们在进行一场非常深刻的对话，聊一些我生活中非常严肃的事情。我突然停顿一下，她就会说，哦，天哪，我知道
just what you're going to say. And I'll be like, well, well, but I have to, there's this one scene in the office where like this is happening. And I just, I use it as like a, this reminds me of that one scene and how they feel here. And I really feel like that right now. It's stupid, guys. Like, you really, you really have raised me in a way. are things that when they sort of get like, I don't know what the phrase is, but like kind of in your bones, you know what I mean? Like, then they become sacred to you. And like, if someone asked you about it, you're like, okay, first of all, how dare you? I know. That is mine. I know. But at the same time, you're like, okay. Yeah, let's talk about it. Yeah. How well do you
你接下来要说什么。然后我会说，好吧，好吧，但我必须说，在《办公室》里有这样一个场景，发生了这样的事。我只是把它当作一个例子，这让我想起了那个场景以及他们在那里感受到的情绪。我现在真的有那种感觉。这很蠢，伙计们。真的，你们真的在某种程度上抚养了我。有些东西，当它们融入了你的骨子里，你知道我的意思吗？然后它们对你来说就变得神圣了。如果有人问你关于它的事，你会想，好吧，首先，怎么着？我知道。那是我的。我知道。但与此同时，你会想，好吧。好吧，我们聊聊。好吧，你有多大
know it? Don't even come at me. I know. Well, that's the other thing is people are like, I love that. And I'm like, I referenced the shit out of this show. And I'll go, does anybody in this room know the office well enough to know like specific details and people go like yeah for sure and I'm like I just know it's not true I go okay so do you know in you know this one episode where where Michael is like doing this and then he's doing this and then somebody comes in and and everybody's like no sorry I don't know and also what's cool is my brother who's seen the office many times he and his girlfriend who's seen the office kind of the way everybody has where you've seen it she's never really watched it all the way through and so they've been watching it all the way through for the first time like as a whole since
了解它？别来找我。我知道。好吧，另一件事是人们会说，我太喜欢那个了。然后我会说，我对这部剧里的梗简直了如指掌。然后我会问，这个房间里有人对《办公室》熟悉到知道具体细节的程度吗？然后大家会说，哦，当然。我说，我就是知道这不是真的。我说，好吧，你知道在某一集中，迈克尔像这样然后像那样，然后有人进来，然后大家都说，哦，对不起，我不知道。而且，很酷的是，我哥哥看了很多遍《办公室》，他和他的女朋友也是那种把剧看了好几遍的人，虽然她从来没有真正从头到尾看过，所以他们最近正在从头到尾第一次完整地看
it came out for phineas too and so for him everything's really fresh and so he's finally like oh billy we were watching we were watching the deposition the other day and that one scene what does he say and i'm like oh you mean yeah yeah oh so this and this and also like sometimes he'll just he'll reference something that he just watched and i'll immediately get the reference and be able to like recite the rest of the scene, which it's like a whole new level of your, like your siblinghood. It really is. I'm like, wow, you can finally. You see me. Yeah. Yeah, it's cool. Do you want to do a scene with us? Oh, yes. Do you want to be in a scene with us? We printed out a scene from the show. Okay, I mean, first of all, Billy, I went to our actual shooting draft. So this is as we held it in our hands. Wow.
菲尼亚斯也是这样，所以对他来说一切都很新鲜。所以他终于会说，哦，比利，我们前几天在看《听证会》那一集，那个场景里他说的是什么？然后我说，哦，你是说，对，对，哦，所以这个和那个……而且，有时候他会随口引用他刚看的某个梗，我能立刻get到那个梗，并且能把剩下的场景背出来。这感觉就像是，把你们的手足情谊提升到了一个全新的高度。真的。我就觉得，哇，你终于。你懂我。对，对，这太酷了。你想和我们一起演个场景吗？哦，好啊。你想和我们一起演个场景吗？我们把剧里的一个场景打印出来了。好吧，首先，比利，我拿到了我们实际拍摄的剧本。所以这是我们当时拿在手里的原件。哇。
Let's see. Oh my gosh, in 2004. This is from 2004. I was two, you guys. Oh, my God. She was two years old. Look, I highlighted your parts. Jenna, you will play Pam. Okay. Wow.
我看看。哦，天哪，2004年的。这是2004年的。我那时候才两岁，伙计们。哦，天哪。她那时候才两岁。看，我把你的台词高亮了。珍娜，你演帕姆。好的。哇。
Billy, you are going to play Phyllis. We are going to do the first ever party planning committee scene. Oh, yeah. I know this scene quite well. Season one, episode four, The Alliance. Sure is. Okay. I'm going to also read our stage direction.
比利，你来演菲利斯。我们要重现史上第一个派对策划委员会的场景。哦，太棒了。这个场景我太熟了。第一季第四集，《同盟》。确实是。好的。我来读一下我们的舞台指示。
Party planning committee. Here we go. Interior Conference Room, Pam, Phyllis, and Angela, semicolon, the party committee. Well, for decorations, maybe we could do, no, that's stupid. Forget it. What? Well, I was going to say we could have streamers, but that's dumb. Everybody has streamers. Never mind. No, yeah. I think that's a good idea. What color do you guys think? Well, there's green, blue, yellow, red.
派对策划委员会。我们开始吧。内景，会议室。帕姆、菲利斯和安吉拉，分号，派对委员会。嗯，至于装饰，也许我们可以弄，不，这太蠢了。算了吧。什么？嗯，我本来想说我们可以挂彩带，但那太傻了。每个人都有彩带。算了。不，对。我觉得这是个好主意。你们觉得什么颜色好？嗯，有绿色、蓝色、黄色、红色。
How about green? I think green is kind of horrish. Woo! You're officially in the PPC! It's so scary. We actually have for you. What do you have? We are in the party planning committee now.
绿色怎么样？我觉得绿色有点像妓女的颜色。哇！你正式加入PPC了！太可怕了。我们实际上为你准备了。准备了什么？我们现在是派对策划委员会的成员了。
We have a party planning committee sweatshirt for you. It's a special. There you go. You can plan as many parties as you want. Or, however, are you the committee to plan parties? Oh. Which one are you? Oh, gosh.
我们为你准备了一件派对策划委员会的运动衫。这是一件特别的。给你。你想办多少派对就办多少派对。或者，到底哪个才是策划派对的委员会？哦。你是哪一个？哦，天哪。
The committee to plan party was a pretty, it's pretty good party planning. Pretty good stuff. I know. Isn't it interesting, though, that the first time this scene was ever written, it's called the party committee. The party committee, I know. One of my favorite lines of yours, it's your one-off and you're like, Michael should have asked the party planning committee first.
策划派对委员会，挺不错的，派对策划。挺不错的东西。我懂。不过很有意思的是，这个场景第一次写出来的时候，它叫派对委员会。派对委员会，我懂。我最喜欢你的其中一句台词，那是你的客串台词，你当时说，迈克尔应该先问问派对策划委员会。
He's not supposed to just spring things on as willy-nilly. And then you just, you're like, the hand-grab to your face of you crying is just, oh, it breaks my heart. Angela's whole, just like, clearly just like miserable life. Repressed. Miserable self. And then, and like, when you throw the, that whole episode, oh, my God. And the Yankee swap, just like how upset you are that it's not going how you want to. it to go. And you had a whole idea for how it was supposed to go. And Michael's just ruining
他不应该就这样随随便便地搞突袭。然后你就，你会觉得，你哭的时候用手捂脸的那个动作，真的是，哦，太让我心碎了。安吉拉整个人，就，很明显就像是一个悲惨的生活。压抑的。悲惨的自己。然后，然后，当你在那一整集中，哦，天哪。还有换礼物环节，你对事情没有按你想要的路线发展感到那么沮丧。你对事情应该怎么发展有一整套设想。而迈克尔却把一切都
everything. And then Dwight kisses Kelly. And it's just, you're just, it's just furious, horrible day for you. And you throw the ornaments. Which by the way, we're supposed to shatter. But they didn't. Yeah, they don't shatter. I threw them and they, in the first take, I threw it and it bounced right back. And I was like trying to stay in character. But at the same time, I'm like, why the hell isn't this breaking? So then just in a pure rage, I just started screaming and stomping them, and that's what made it in. Your character is just everybody is Pam, you know? I feel like that's everyone's Pam, you know?
搞砸了。然后德怀特吻了凯利。然后就是，你只是，这绝对是你愤怒、糟糕透顶的一天。然后你扔了装饰品。顺便说一句，这些装饰品本来是应该摔碎的。但它们没有。对，它们没有碎。我把它们扔了，然后它们，在第一次拍摄时，我扔出去，结果它直接反弹回来了。我当时还试图保持角色状态。但与此同时，我又在想，这到底为什么不碎？然后在一阵纯粹的愤怒中，我开始尖叫并猛踩它们，这就是最终剪进正片的内容。你的角色就是每个人都是帕姆，你知道吗？我觉得那是每个人的帕姆，你知道吗？
And I also love the way that Roy is written because it's so perfectly, he's got charm to him and he's got like, you can see it, but also he's so neglectful and like emotionally abusive that it's like you can totally see how you could get there. My dad had a saying for guys like that. He used to say, well, Ange, he's not a bad guy, but he's not worth much. And I'm like, that was Roy. That was Roy. It just made you feel like so shitty, you know?
而且我也很喜欢罗伊这个角色的塑造，因为它太完美了，他有一种迷人之处，而且他有一种，你能看得出来，但同时他又那么玩忽职守，而且有精神虐待倾向，所以你会完全明白你是怎么走到这一步的。我爸爸对那种男人有一句名言。他过去常说，嗯，安吉，他不是个坏人，但他也没什么价值。而我想说，那就是罗伊。那就是罗伊。这真的让你感觉糟透了，你知道吗？
It's just like so, oh, God, it's so good. And it's just like everything about Pam is just so heartbreaking. And just like, you really, you do it perfectly. Everything about it is perfect. Thank you. Guys, I'm serious. Like, the show, it just can't be beat. It just really can't.
这真的是，哦，天哪，太棒了。而且关于帕姆的一切都太让人心碎了。真的，你演得太完美了。关于它的一切都是完美的。谢谢。伙计们，我是认真的。这个剧，真的是无可匹敌。真的无可匹敌。
I like a lot of shows, but it just, it's just the one, guys. I'm serious. We have two things we can do here. If you have any more questions for us, we've asked you all of our questions. So if you have any more questions for us, please ask. Also, we did prepare an office quiz that we would take against each other, and we don't know the answers. We don't know who would win. Would you like? By the way, we would love to do that. We haven't seen the questions. We don't know. Cassie prepared them. We haven't gotten to season eight yet. If you ask me a question from season eight, I'm not even going to know, because I haven't watched season eight since we filmed it. So that's like... Okay. So we'll intro the quiz then.
我喜欢很多剧，但这个，它就是那个唯一的剧，伙计们。我是认真的。我们这里有两件事可以做。如果你还有什么问题想问我们，我们已经问了你所有的问题。所以如果你还有什么问题想问我们，请尽管提。另外，我们确实准备了一份办公室问答，我们要用它来互相切题，而且我们不知道答案。我们不知道谁会赢。你们想不想？顺便说一句，我们很乐意这么做。我们还没看过这些问题。我们不知道。卡西准备的。我们还没看到第八季呢。如果你问我一个关于第八季的问题，我甚至都答不上来，因为自从我们拍完第八季后我就再也没看过。所以这就好比……好吧。那我们就先介绍一下这个问答环节吧。
We'll say... Okay, so here's another interesting thing is that I just, every time I watch it all the way through, because again, I started from the beginning, and I finish it every time. I can't believe I do that. So where are you right now in this rewind? I finished it. Oh, you just recently finished it again. I finished it like a couple weeks ago. Okay. Every time I finish it, I take a couple weeks off, and then I started over. Okay. So I'm in my weeks off period. Okay. Which means, it's not right here. It's here. Billy, I'm pretty sure it's just in your DNA now. I think it is. I think it is. But for instance, and I think about this all the time, when Rain came over and did the office quiz with me, I was watching it, but I hadn't gotten to when Nelly is in the show. Yeah. And so she wasn't on my mind. I was just not there yet. And so he asked me a question about Nellie. And also I was nervous as shit. Dwight shirt sitting in my front of my face in my parents' house. And I was 16. Like, oh, my God. I was.
我们会说……好吧，所以另一件有趣的事是，我只是，每次我把整部剧从头看到尾时，因为再次声明，我是从头开始看的，而且每次我都把它看完。真不敢相信我竟然会这样做。那你现在在这个重温进度里看到哪了？我已经看完了。哦，你最近又把它看完了。我大概几周前把它看完了。好吧。每次我看完美剧，我都会休息几周，然后再重新开始。好吧。所以我现在正处于休息周期间。好吧。这意味着，它不在这里。它在这里。比利，我敢肯定它已经融入你的DNA里了。我想是的。我想是的。但举个例子，而且我经常这样想，当雷恩过来和我一起做办公室问答时，我正在看这部剧，但我还没看到内莉出场的那一集。对。所以她当时不在我的脑海里。我还没看到那儿。所以他问了我一个关于内莉的问题。而且我当时紧张得要命。德怀特衬衫穿在我父母家里的我面前。而我当时才16岁。就像，哦，天哪。我当时
was so intimidated and nervous that when he asked me a question about Nelly, I just like, my brain just didn't work. And I just like forgot about her character for two seconds. And it was, until you said her name, I forgot like Catherine Tate's character's name was. Nelly character question. I completely forgot. Because we haven't gotten there yet. Yeah. Okay. Here we go. Here we go. Office quiz with Billie Eilish. Uh-huh. Yes. Starting hopefully from easy questions and it'll get harder. Oh, my God. Cassie. Okay. How many questions are there? There's 10. Is it just anybody shouted out, whoever's first? I think so.
太紧张、太局促了，以至于当他问我关于内莉的问题时，我的大脑直接当机了。我足足有两秒钟把她的角色给忘了。直到你说了她的名字，我才想起来凯瑟琳·泰特饰演的角色的名字是什么。内莉的角色问题。我完全忘光了。因为我们还没看到那儿。好吧。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。与比利·艾利什一起进行的办公室问答。嗯哼。是的。希望从简单的题目开始，然后难度会逐渐增加。哦，天哪。卡西。好吧。一共有多少道题？一共有10道。是不是谁先抢答就算谁的？我想是的。
But then you said Cassie, if we shouted at the same time, we each get a point and she has tiebreakers at the end. Okay. What? I didn't know any of these rules? Okay. Oh, yeah, sorry, that was a private conversation I had with Cassie. I didn't tell you. Okay.
但你刚才说卡西，如果我们同时抢答，我们每人得一分，她在最后有决胜题。什么？我怎么不知道这些规则？好吧。哦，对了，抱歉，那是我和卡西的私下对话。我没告诉你。好吧。
All right. Here we go. What body part did Michael accidentally grill because he likes to wear his foot? Angela got it first. Okay, I didn't realize we could break in before the question was over. Yeah, it's true. See, I'm a rule follower for the end. No, it's vicious.
好了。我们开始吧。迈克尔不小心烤了身体的哪个部位，因为他喜欢把脚……安吉拉第一个抢答出来。好吧，我没意识到我们可以在问题结束前就抢答。对，确实如此。你看，我可是个墨守成规的人。不，这太残酷了。
I'm slightly competitive. Number two, besides the bride, who wore white to Phyllis' wedding? Oh, that was so good. Okay. Three. What does Michael give Toby as a goodbye present? A rock. It's a brick.
我稍微有点好胜心。第二题，除了新娘之外，谁在菲莉丝的婚礼上穿了白色？哦，这太棒了。好吧。第三题。迈克尔送给托比什么离别礼物？一块石头。是一块砖头。
It's a brick. No, it's a rock. It's a rock. It's a post-it note with a, um... Rubber band around. And what does the Post-it notes say? Suck it. Suck on this, guys.
是一块砖头。不，是一块石头。是一块石头。是一张便签，上面写着，嗯……缠着一根橡皮筋。便签上写的是什么？去你的。吃这个吧，伙计们。
Suck on this. Oh my God. Suck it is David Wallace's invention. I know. I knew Suck was on it. I knew suck was on this. Okay. All right.
吃这个。哦，天哪。“吃这个”是大卫·华莱士的发明。我知道。我知道上面写着“吃”。我知道上面写着“吃”。好吧。好吧。
Who are the members of the Finer Things Club? Oscar, Pam, Toby. Y. Angela got it. I just stayed quiet on that one. You guys killed it. All right. Bonus.
精英文学俱乐部的成员有哪些？奥斯卡、帕姆、托比。耶。安吉拉答对了。我那题保持沉默了。你们太厉害了。好吧。加分题。
Who wants to join? Me, Angela. No, Andy. Andy. I think Billy goes. Literally screaming. I think I just wanted to join in real life. Okay.
谁想加入？我，安吉拉。不，安迪。安迪。我觉得比利抢到了。简直在尖叫。我想我只是想在现实生活中加入。好吧。
What is Stanley's favorite day? Pressle Day. I feel like they all got it. Yeah. Okay, good. Finally. All right. In second life, Dwight creates a character that is exactly like himself in real life.
斯坦利最喜欢什么日子？プレゼル日（椒盐卷饼日）。我觉得他们都答出来了。对。很好。终于。好吧。在《第二人生》中，德怀特创造了一个什么样的角色？这个角色在现实生活中和他一模一样。
But he can fly. But he can fly. All right. What's the name of the song Jan keeps playing during dinner party? That one night. I don't know what the name is. They don't ever talk about the name. By Hunter.
但他会飞。但他会飞。好吧。简在晚宴派对上一直放的那首歌叫什么名字？那一晚。我不知道歌名是什么。他们从来没提过歌名。亨特写的。
By Hunter. That one night. Yeah. But they never talk about the name ever. Oh. Oh, so maybe it's not called that one night. It's just that's all you hear. She could contest that.
亨特写的。那一晚。对。但他们从来没提过歌名。哦。哦，所以也许它不叫《那一晚》？这只是你听到的全部。她可以对此提出异议。
That's just the song. Listen, I don't think my point on that one is going to make any impact on the final score. Okay. Okay. Who is Gabe often mistaken as? Uh, Lincoln. Abraham Lincoln. Oh.
那只是那首歌。听着，我觉得我在那道题上的得分不会对最终分数产生任何影响。好吧。好吧。盖布经常被误认为是谁？呃，林肯。亚伯拉罕·林肯。哦。
I was going to say a praying mantis. Does someone say that? A stick bug. A stick bug. Oh, gosh. All right. This is a fill in the blank question. Oh, gosh.
我本来想说祈祷螳螂。有人这么说过吗？竹节虫。竹节虫。哦，天哪。好吧。这是一道填空题。哦，天哪。
If Creed can't blank. Scooba. Scuba, yeah. Good one. What's it all been for? Yeah. All right. So right now, the score is Billy has six, Angela is four.
如果克里德不能……潜水。潜水，对。答得好。这一切都是为了什么？对。好吧。所以目前，比分为比利6分，安吉拉4分。
Jenna has two. Oh, wow. So sad. That way. I will give you a point. for as many names as you can come up with this question. What? Name Angela Martin's cats.
珍娜2分。哦，天哪。太惨了。这样吧。只要你能说出这道题中尽可能多的名字，我就给你加分。什么？说出安吉拉·马丁的猫的名字。
Amber, Ash, sprinkles, bandit, lumpy, bandage. Garbage. Well, garbage, I guess she does keep in touch. Lady Princess. Princess Lady. Princess Lady. Ash. Diane.
安布尔、阿什、斯普林克尔斯、班迪特、兰皮、班戴奇。加比奇。嗯，加比奇，我想她确实和它保持着联系。丽迪公主。公主女士。公主女士。阿什。黛安。
Diane. Um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, comstock. Yeah. Oh, Comstock. Um, um, well, okay, but I don't know. how many we did we both were doing yeah i said i said amber ash we got sprinkles lumpy amber ash bandit princess lady princess lady diane um miss mr ash right that's mr ash did you say garbage we got garbage so sprinkles obviously are there more what are we missing more how many
黛安。嗯……康斯托克。对。哦，康斯托克。嗯……好吧，但是，我不知道我们说对了多少，我们俩都在说，对，我说过，我说过安布尔、阿什，我们有斯普林克尔斯、兰皮、安布尔、阿什、班迪特、公主女士、公主女士、黛安、嗯……阿什先生，对，那是阿什先生，你说了加比奇吗？我们有加比奇，所以斯普林克尔斯显然是，还有更多的吗？我们漏掉了什么？还有多少
more there's like 13 isn't there yeah there's 14 wait wait wait yeah i knew there were like 13 Yeah, there's eight left. The one with the, um... Is there one named Jenny? No. Does she say them all when... When Dwight is saying that he doesn't like sleeping on... No, she only says like four.
更多的？大概有13只，对吧？对，有14只，等等，等等，对，我知道大概有13只。对，还剩8只。那只带着，嗯……有一只叫珍妮吗？没有。当德怀特说他不喜欢睡在……不，她只说了四只。
She says... Yeah, only four. Ash, lumpy, Diane. Oh, there's some... There's another one. I'm thinking of what letters that start with? Give me a letter. Wait, wait, wait.
她说……对，只有四只。阿什、兰皮、黛安。哦，还有一些……还有一只。我想想它是以什么字母开头的？给我一个字母。等等，等等。
Is it the one that's humping princess lady that we're forgetting or did we get him? I think that's Mr. Ash. Yeah, that's right. Mr. Ash. Give me, give me one, a letter that sits with them. There are two that start with P. It's your cat.
是我们忘的那只正在对公主女士进行“爱的运动”的猫，还是我们已经猜到了？我想那是阿什先生。对，没错，阿什先生。给我，给我一个，跟它们有关的字母。有两个是以P开头的。那是你的猫。
Oh, yes. Two that start with P? Mm-hmm. Mm. Oh, gosh. Oh, my God. I can, Peter? Nope.
哦，对。两个以P开头的？嗯哼。嗯。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我可以，彼得？不对。
No. Paul? No. No. I'm just saying, I'm saying, like, people with precious. Oh. Princess lady, Diane, lumpy. Uh, Mr. Ash.
不对。保罗？不对。不对。我是说，我是说，比如叫皮谢斯的。哦。公主女士、黛安、兰皮。呃，阿什先生。
I can so picture it. Mm-hmm. Piny. No. I'm just making it. I'm trying to think of another P one. We have a hint. I have a hint.
我脑海里太有画面感了。嗯哼。皮尼？不对。我瞎编的。我在想另一个以P开头的名字。我们有一个提示。我有一个提示。
You also name your children this. What? You name your children this. Like, it's a kid name? Yeah, it's like Angela Martin named her kid after. Philip! Yes! You have a cat named Philip?
你也给你的孩子起这个名字。什么？你给你的孩子起这个名字。就像，这是一个小孩的名字？对，就像安吉拉·马丁给她的孩子起名叫……菲利普！对！你有一只猫叫菲利普？
I didn't realize that. Oh, because you named after your cat. That's right. Because it was named after my grandfather. But it was named after Angel's cat. Yes, because you're like the same-up for my girlfriend. It's named after my cat. It's after my cat.
我没意识到这一点。哦，因为你是用你的猫的名字给孩子起名的。没错。因为它是以我爷爷的名字命名的。但它是以安吉拉的猫命名的。对，因为你就像是“为我爷爷起的名字。它是以我的猫的名字命名的。它是以我的猫的名字命名的。”
Oh, my God. That's tricky. Okay, what's our score? What's our tally? Our score is, Jenna, you still only had two points. What? I said garbage. Okay, okay.
哦，天哪。这太狡猾了。好吧，我们的比分是多少？我们的总分是多少？我们的比分是，珍娜，你依然只有两分。什么？我说过加比奇。好吧，好吧。
I'll give you one. No, fine. It was embarrassing. Okay, fine, you have three points. Angela, you have seven points. Billy, you have ten points. Well, Billy, thank you so much for coming in and chatting with us. This was an absolute delight.
我给你加一分。不，好吧。刚才太尴尬了。好吧，好吧，你有三分。安吉拉，你有七分。比利，你有十分。好吧，比利，非常感谢你来和我们聊天。这真的是一段绝对令人愉快的时光。
We could talk to you all day. We do. Thank you. We just love you so much. We're so happy to have spent this time with you. I will come back whenever you want me. Yay! Good guys.
我们可以跟你聊一整天。我们会的。谢谢。我们太喜欢你了。很高兴能和你度过这段时光。只要你们想让我来，我随时都会来。耶！太棒了，伙计们。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Ratton. For ad-free versions of Office ladies,
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·吉尔金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·拉顿的《橡树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，
go to stitcher premium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问stitcher premium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码：office。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。